This is Jocko podcast
with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo and tonight's
podcast is a little bit different,
but I think it has some
good information in it.
I was asked by two people
who have outstanding podcasts
of their own to sit down
and have a conversation about leadership
and specifically leadership inside of
atrocities,
and when we recorded it,
I wasn't really expecting it,
but we decided that we would all
release it on our podcast platforms.
So the two people that
I recorded this with,
our Danieli Bolelli and Daryl Cooper,
unfortunately Echo Charles was
not present for this recording
and Danieli Bolelli. First of
all, he's a history professor.
He's a martial artist, he's an
author and yes, he's a podcaster.
He has two podcasts that
are great to listen to.
The great podcast.
One is called the drunk and towers,
and the other one is history on fire.
They're great podcasts there, entertaining
podcast, they're educational. They're,
like I said,
they're super informative and the
podcast that you're about to listen to is
based on a couple other podcasts.
The first one being bye Daniellie from
his history on fire podcast number 32
Alpha 32 a for civilians out there and
the the podcast is about the sand creek
massacre, which took place
in present day Kiowa County,
Colorado on November 29th,
1864 where there were about somewhere
between 70 and 170 Cheyenne,
Arapaho Indians,
mostly women and children
who were slaughtered by a 675 man force
of the Colorado us volunteer cavalry,
brutal situation,
horrible situation and like I said,
Danieli.
Billy talks about that on his history
on fire podcast number 32 alpha.
The other podcast,
this is related to is from Darryl Cooper's
podcasts has his podcast is called
the martyrmade podcast and specifically
podcast number 10 it's about the me Lai
massacre
and that is when about
500 innocent civilians.
Again,
mostly women and children were murdered
and many also raped and mutilated by US
soldiers in Vietnam.
Daryl Cooper is also an
incredible podcast. Her.
He's a great storyteller and
he goes through ridiculous,
I would say depths to give all
perspectives of a story. And He,
his podcast martyrmade is fantastic.
He doesn't put them out off
as often as I wish he would.
But the podcasts are great.
The one on the Palestinian Israeli
conflict that he started his first,
I think it's his first six podcasts
on martyrmade. That's what it's about.
And they're fantastic.
And he's a veteran of the u s navy.
He's a wrestler,
he's a Jujitsu player,
and he's really smart,
well read person and great to listen to.
And then the last podcast
is my own podcast,
Jocko podcast number 31
four hours in me lie,
which is when I did an assessment of a
book by that name and talked about that
same massacre in Vietnam and in this
podcast that you're about to listen to,
the three of us discuss how
these atrocities come about
and what can be done to
prevent them in the future.
So that's the lay down.
And here it is.
Daniella, Jocko, everybody.
I'm here. Daryl Cooper, uh,
talking to two of my favorite people.
Um,
we're going to go some dark places today.
You've listened to the last two podcasts
with Daniella and I have put out and
maybe about 60% of the podcast
that Jocko was put out. And then,
you know, we're gonna we're going
to dive into some dark places. Um,
I want to get it started pretty quick.
We've been talking beforehand so
let's just jump right into it. Um,
Daniella and I recently
did a series that we uh,
cooperated on where he covered the sand
creek massacre in 1864 some US army
soldiers, uh, massacred some
native Americans in Colorado. Um,
I did the I massacre,
um,
similar situation 104 years later
in the jungles of Vietnam. Um,
we're fortunate enough to be here with
Jocko. If you don't know who Jocko is a,
I guess we'll go ahead and let you
introduce yourself just a little bit.
Yeah,
my name is Jocko Willink.
Guy Was in the military for 20 years
and retired in 2010 and now I written a
couple books and have a podcast called
Jocko podcast cause I don't get really
creative with the names of things.
So
jacos pretty direct about things.
So I was also kind of humble.
Jocko is a navy seal commander in Iraq.
He led taskforce bruiser.
Is that right into a task unit bruiser
bruiser into the battle of Ramadi shift,
you know, anything about, uh,
the war in Iraq. You know,
the battle of Ramadi in the battle of
Fallujah are probably the two big fights
that get mentioned the most.
We're asked.
Volusia was more of an more of a
direct assault on the city after,
uh,
after the insurgence captured and tortured
and mutilated some us contractors and
Bush ordered the Marines to retaliate.
The battle of Ramadi was a
little bit different. Uh,
Jack was going to talk a little bit about
the environment that they went into,
uh, going into it. And so he's
got some military experience,
not only being on the ground,
but of leading men in battle,
in an environment and insurgent war where
you've got different groups of people,
different sex,
the Sunni and the Shia Anorak who are
fighting a bloody battle that we're in the
middle of, but who we can't engage
with on their level. You know,
these are people who are fighting a very,
very dirty and ugly war against
one another. And against us,
if they get their hands on us as
Americans, I'm going into a war like that.
You know,
we've got,
we've got a different mentality and
we try to avoid behaving in ways that
dishonor us. And uh, it's something
that Jocko takes very seriously and he,
he had to lead men into combat under those
conditions. So we can talk about that.
It was 2006, April of 2006 when you
lead, you met into Ramadi to begin with,
is that right? Yes, that's what it
was. So, uh, shortly before that,
a couple months before the golden dome
of the Alis scarred mosque was blown up
by al Qaeda in Iraq.
Zarqawi is people.
This is an ancient Shia mosque,
one of the most sacred
places to s to Shia Islam.
Well, interestingly, Ramadi was,
is primarily Sunni. In fact,
it's almost all SUNY and interestingly
the majority of the military forces in
Iraq,
especially the army or were Shia.
And so you had to kind of diffuse that
tension on a pretty regular basis to make
sure that there weren't,
you know,
reprisal killings and the,
there was definitely some
level of mistrust between
the Sunni's that lived there
in the city and the Shia military.
But it's definitely, it's,
it's absolutely,
it was absolutely clear that the,
the Sunni's that lived in Ramadi,
the local Sunni's that lived in Ramadi,
much preferred the Shia army soldiers
to the insurgents that were there that
were being run by al Qaeda in
Iraq by Zarqawi and the likes.
And because what they were doing
was just savagery and you know,
everything that you hear about,
they were skinning people alive.
They were beheading whole families. They
were torturing, raping, and murdering,
murdering the local populace in to get
them to support them as much as they
could through pure terror.
And so the local populace,
even though they might not
have been, you know, they're,
they're basically going with who's
their worst enemy at the time.
Their worst enemy at the time was
without question al Qaeda in Iraq.
And so the she army that was there to
fight al Qaeda in Iraq, the Sunni's were,
we're generally in support of what
the army was doing there. So it was,
it was a little bit different than an
areas like solder city where the, the,
she is in solder city,
we're very active.
There was an active fight going
on against coalition forces.
So yeah, it's uh, it's
definitely a tricky situation
when you,
when you roll into a situation like that
with American soldiers where both sides
are engaged in just a
hurricane of atrocities across
the country and where the
people who are there,
they might be looking to you for safety
or I guess that's a question I would
have a, they probably under
the circumstances where
the people in the city,
I mean they probably were
looking to you to protect them.
Absolutely. And just before
we showed up, just to,
just to kind of paint this
as clear as I can and,
and I forget the exact numbers
and I apologize for that,
but just before we showed up,
the insurgents murdered,
it was something like seven,
eight,
nine 10 of the leading tribal shakes
in the area and the tribal shakes that
survive for that left,
they left.
And so that just put the whole,
the whole city,
you know,
under such a grip of fear
of the insurgents that they
just basically surrendered
as much as you can
surrender, which means, hey,
if you want to come and stay at my house
and you want to sit in my backyard and
launch mortars at the coalition forces,
we're not going to say anything to you
because we're going to, we want to live,
we don't want to get killed.
And that's what you end up with.
You end up with passive support.
And that's what the locals were doing.
They were passively supporting
the insurgents only because
they didn't want to
have their heads cut off.
And so as we,
and this was a brilliant strategy that
was spearheaded by the one one the,
the ready First Brigade of
the First Armored Division
run by a guy named Colonel
Sean Mcfarlin who ended
up being a general,
and he's a brilliant guy and a
great leader, but you know, his eye,
his attitude,
which he actually got from HR McMaster,
which he had employed up in
California and, and uh, one,
one 80 had actually gone into telephone
and gotten a turnover and understood
what they had done up and Telefonica and
the strategy was called cs clear hold
and build,
which was going to be his enemy controlled
territory's these Enderby controlled
neighborhoods and stay there. And so
that's what, that's what the strategy was.
And that was a lot different then the
strategy that had been being used up until
this point, not just in
Ramadi button, all of Iraq.
Is that a strategy that it almost seems
like looking at reading about Ramadi
from the outside of somebody
who's never been in combat,
it almost seems like the goal was to go
in there and establish your dominance
over the city.
Almost to show the people of the city
that you don't have to be afraid of these
people because they were
afraid of us and we're gonna,
we have freedom in this city.
We can take our Humvees and patrol the
streets and they're not going to come out
and fight us because they're afraid of us.
And so you don't have to fear them.
It almost seems like
that was the goal there.
Yeah. I wouldn't use the word dominance
because we weren't trying to dominate the
local populace. We were trying to provide
security for the local population.
And obviously that's a big difference
because when you start having an attitude
of we're going to dominate
the local populace,
that that's just a small step
in the wrong direction. Right?
That's a small step in the wrong
direction. Whereas saying, Hey,
we're here to protect and secure and
stabilize the local populace, that is,
that is what we were doing.
Yeah. I think it took us maybe a little
bit longer than we wish it would have to,
uh, recognize that before you can
do anything counterinsurgency,
you have to provide security
to the people hundred percent.
You're not leaving them a choice,
then they're going to provide that passive
port.
Right,
and I think that's one of the shows that
shows up with the kind of episodes we
did. You know both the story of
San Creek and story of me lie.
You have a situation in which sad than
the some guys making to look everybody on
the quote unquote other side
as belonging to the same field.
The Hawaii because they are all
Cheyenne or they are old Vietnamese,
they are all, there's no signs that
they are not all in the same boat.
Some people are your ally,
some people are your enemies.
Some people are exactly
what you are saying.
Stacking between where I kind of
have to cooperate with your enemies,
not because I want to buy because I
really have no other choice and you cannot
treat all of them the same way.
And so I think the dilemma you are facing,
this idea of having to figure out,
okay,
there are people that worry or to protect.
Those are not the people who going after.
There are other people that
we need to take care of.
That seems to be one of the scenes that
was Betty matched me scene. You know,
that nuance,
that ability to look at people who may
look the same way but they are not the
same people to look at them
it with different eyes.
That seemed to be really
well was me seeding some of
the stories that we treated
where the guys who did what they did
is because to damn is like an Indiana,
he's an Indian, Vietnamese, Vietnamese,
whatever. It's all the same,
doesn't really matter.
And I think he's like ow.
Do you see one leads to that
point on one side and vice versa?
What is the you guys were doing to make
sure that it doesn't go to that point
where your guys would not make that
switch to that frame of mind and keeping
their priorities very clear in terms of
differentiating in terms of who they are
facing. And real quick,
can I just add up? Yeah.
Supplement to that question because that's
kind of what I wanted to ask as well
as, uh, how do you,
how do you train your men and lead your
men in such a way that they can pull the
trigger when they have to and when
civilians get killed on, you know,
accidentally that that doesn't
destroy them emotionally. Right?
There's gotta be some kind of separation
there without having them fully enter
over into that mindset that Danielle,
he's talking about where you're just
dehumanizing the enemy all together when
you have to lead your men in a
situation like that. Like how did did,
how did you deal with that?
Yeah. Well, this is leadership. This is
leadership and this is leadership in war.
And this is, you know, this, this question
that you're asking is the, you know,
one of the largest possible questions
you could ask about combat leadership and
you know, you, you, I appreciate that
you guys keep referring to me, but I was,
I had 35 or 40 seals there
depending on the time.
And there was 5,600 soldiers and
Marines would that were there that were
discriminating targets every single day
and that had outstanding leadership that
we're, that we're making sure that
guys with less training than my guys,
guys that were younger than my guys,
guys that had a tougher job than my guys
in many cases would still discriminate
targets and make sure that they were,
were engaging enemy
personnel and not civilians.
Now I'm certainly not saying
that civilians didn't get
killed because civilians
got killed and it's an awful thing and
it's one of the things I talk about all
the time.
If you go to war and you're
not comfortable with the
fact that you're going to
kill innocent people, then you probably
don't have the will to go to war.
And maybe what you're
going to war for isn't,
doesn't meet the threshold
of what warrants a war. And,
and if that's what the conclusion
you come to, that's fine. You know,
let's hope you come to it before you've,
before you've been before,
you're on the ground and,
and blood has been spilled.
But there's so many little things to that.
Would that would, that, you know,
that we'd cover to talk about, I mean,
just even the distinction that I
just made between like, hey, we're,
we're going in there to dominate.
That's a little step.
It's one little step and using
that word and then following it up.
And we talked a little
bit about this and Daryl,
I was listening to your podcast
about the meal. I'm asking her and I,
and I did one about it as well. And
one of the things that, that really,
that I talked about in pretty
great depth because for me I had,
I had incredible correlate correlation
between what happened in me life and what
I sometimes saw happen overseas.
And that was with the intelligence
that you're receiving.
And you could see,
and I pointed it out in my podcast and
I don't remember like all the exact
verbiage, but you know, at the
senior levels of intelligence,
the intelligence report was that Pinkville
or the area of Pinkville or me lie
whenever you want to call it me
lie for that, that area, the,
the initial intelligence was,
you know,
suspected Vietnamese in
the or suspected Viet Cong,
uh,
area could be possible,
you know,
Vietcong.
And then it went down one level in the
chain of command and the next people that
briefed it, it was just a little
bit stronger. You know, it was
v, you know, Vietcong area,
Vietcong controlled area,
and then it went down one more
level and it was Viet Cong, uh,
headquarters area. And then it
got down to, this is all Vietcong.
And then they threw in the,
the fact that, you know, the,
the, the people go into the market,
right? It's market day. You know,
that started off as, hey, some people
will be at the market on this day.
And by the time it got to the guys on the
ground it was every one that's good is
going to be at the market.
Everyone that's still in the
village is going to be bad.
They're going to be VC and well
you know what to do with VC.
Yeah. What'd he say? He's,
he's really interesting in terms of just
human communication. Oh, in that case,
before you even go about
Americans and Vietnamese,
you even discuss who are or lead.
Just the basics of human communication.
Now sometime [inaudible] one
degree off before you know it,
if you keep it long enough,
the one degree off to Q so far off course
from the reality they are trying to
describe that the awards switch
is kind of like playing telephone.
You know when you, we spare
something in the other person's here.
It doesn't sound that different from
what you just heard by you just tweak it.
Just a tiny beat by the
time you down 20 people.
The message as no similarity
whatsoever to the original one.
And it seems like that as I think we do,
we told the time in daily life,
but nobody dies as a result of it.
Whereas in that Chi kind of scenario,
people do die.
The consequences are so much more
dramatic as a result of that.
And what's interesting is,
and Darryl,
you kind of brought up in your podcast
and and you did as well, Daniel,
is how does this happen?
Right? How does this happen?
Because if you take a normal human being
and you drop them into the middle of
that thing, they look around and they
go, what the hell is happening? Which is,
which is actually what
happened when, uh, when, uh,
Hugh Thompson came in his helicopter,
he dropped into this situation and said,
what the Hell's going on here?
This is totally wrong. Uh,
but as you're, as you're getting
there, if you're not on that trip,
if you're not on that train as
it's going off the rails, you,
you don't recognize it.
And that's why one thing I talk about all
the time from a leadership perspective
is the ability to detach from all the
chaos and all the mayhem that's happening.
Because if you don't have to,
if you don't have the ability to
detach from that chaos, you're in it.
And if you're in the chaos as a leader,
you don't see the mayhem that's happening.
And so it's so important for a
leader in the business world,
but certainly in the military,
to be able or in any leadership position,
to be able to step back and,
and observe what's actually happening
from a detached perspective.
Because otherwise you're in the storm.
And that is not a good
place to be as a leader.
You've got to have rules for how you're
going to behave before while you're
going into it. Because
if you just, you know,
if you're going to react to everything on
the ground once you arrive, uh, I mean,
it's always expedient to just shoot them.
You know,
at the time it's always easier and safer
probably to just do the easy thing and
be violent or whatever. So you have
to have rules going into it. Um,
did you have to guess the
one thing that I want,
because the poetry of bidding
stuff is super interesting,
but I think essentially what you're
saying is that the person in a position of
leadership needs to be as an master.
You know,
they need to be in the middle of emotions
that clearly are affecting everyone
around them and they are bombarded day
are getting bombarded windows, emotions.
They need to be completely
detached from this stuff.
It makes perfect sense.
Do you do it?
Cause it's a hell of a lot
easier said than done clearly.
And I would do people even
terrain to get to that place.
Well for one thing,
when I was running the training
for the west coast seal teams,
I would fire up that training
to a point that it was,
there was total temptation for the
leaders to get wrapped into the scenarios
that I was developing for them.
There'd be total mayhem and if they let
it happen they would get wrapped up in
these horrible scenarios mentally,
emotionally they'd be mad.
They'd be mad at me cause I was the
guy that was running the training.
They'd be mad at the opposing force
roleplayers they'd be mad at their guys.
They'd start yelling and screaming,
they'd make bad decisions and,
and I wanted them to get there because
I wanted them to see what happens when
you get wrapped up in this
stuff emotionally. So,
and then what I would do is teach them
that they have certain what I would call
red flags,
certain certain signals that they
need to learn how to pick up.
If you feel yourself
start raising your voice,
well then that probably indicates that
you might get be getting emotional if
you're breathing heavy,
if your fists are clenched.
There's all these things that you start
to recognize and once you can recognize
them and you say, okay, I'm
starting to get emotional
right now, need to step back.
Now interestingly,
what I would often do an easy methodology
for training these guys was first of
all, stop looking down the sights of
your weapon like you're not allowed to.
And we'd give,
we'd give a liter of stick if we had to.
And take their guns away so that
they weren't going to be shooting.
They weren't going to be wrapped up in
that tactical situation and literally put
that weapon at high port and step
back away from the firing line.
You know Kelly Kelly is with
his m 16 gunning people down.
He's completely wrapped up in what's
happening. Medina's yelling and screaming.
I mean I talk about this with,
with police forces as well.
If you want to hear people go,
go listen to some of the bad shootings
that you hear and police have a
incredibly hard job.
They need way more training.
But go listen to some of those shootings
that take place and listen to the pitch
and the tone of the officer if and, and
what are they doing? They're saying, God,
I'm good to get out there. They're
completely emotional, right?
And that emotion is going to
drive bad decision making.
So you have to learn how to detach.
The way you do it is in a way I would
initially teach guys to do it is by
physically putting their
weapon at high port,
stepping back away from
the actual firing line.
And look moving their head around
and looking around. You know,
so Bob Story I wrote about an
extreme ownership is, you know, we,
I had w w the, the Delta platoon
commander who's a great guy,
smart guy,
you know,
Ivy League Naval Academy and
just a brilliant guy, great guy.
And he was,
we were doing some training and it was
in Humvees and we were doing immediate
action drills and Humvees
here out in the desert.
And your targets pop up and you
engage the target. It's like,
it's like being mini tank commanders and
you've got five vehicles and you've got
to maneuver them on the battlefield while
they provide cover fire for each other.
And it's, it's a little bit chaotic.
There's big machine guns shooting. And,
and when I was going with him
and I was sitting behind him,
observing him do this,
and every time the shooting we started,
he would kind of lock up, right?
He'd kind of like lock up.
There's so much happening that he
wasn't processing it quick enough.
And so I took a sharpie magic marker
and I, and I, and I wrote down,
um, on the window in front of
his face, I wrote w, Haggai,
here's what I want you to do. And
when, when the shooting starts,
I want you to this one,
relax to look around three,
make a call.
And at that time,
I hadn't thought through this stuff as
much as I have now because I've been
doing it for much longer.
But what I was telling him to do was
detached from what's happening and,
and the way you do that, as
you relax, you look around and,
and then you get on the, the radio
and you make a call and you know,
the next run I watched him and I'll sit
in behind him and I'm looking over his
shoulder. And once the shooting starts,
you can't hear anything. So I'm just,
just watching him and I,
I see the shooting stars and I see him
look at the window and I seen him take a
deep breath and exhale.
And I was like, okay.
He just relaxed and I see his head to
start to turn. And I realize, okay,
now he's looking around and, and, and he,
that those two simple items were enough
to make him detach from all that chaos,
actually assess what is happening
and then make a good decision.
And so that is one of the most important
things that you can train a leader to
do.
Sounds like coaching a Jujitsu white belt.
First thing you tell them they're on the
ground getting beat on and they kind of,
first thing you tell him Bri,
Bri relaxed until you can do that,
then nothing's going to work. Yeah, it's
one of those, it's one of those things to,
people talk about like breathing
exercises and one thing that I would
instinctively do,
and it's another thing that I would train
my guys to do was like you don't panic
on the radio. You don't yell on the
radio, you don't scream on the radio.
You no matter what's going on,
when you get on the radio you say,
you know bruiser one six, this is bruiser
over. I mean that's, that's what you do.
And in order to do that,
you have to relax you.
So it forces you, if you're not
going to sound panicked on the radio,
which if you sound panic on the radio and,
and your team hears it,
guess what? You're going to have panic
going on. So you have to, it's another,
it's another method to detach. So when
you hear your voice getting excited,
when you know,
when you read about Lieutenant Calley
yelling and you hear about Medina yelling,
uh, that, that w, you know,
Kelly started yelling likely
because Medina was yelling at him.
And now that's what happens.
We're just,
we're just sending that panic through
the chain of command and it's a,
it's a horrible,
horrible thing.
I think what's fascinating about it is
that parallels even to the scenario you
artists,
could I be [inaudible] the 99% of the
people at least sitting 99% of the human
beings would never have to deal with
because they are never going to be in
common. But which bullets flying
all around them and all of that.
And yet it's easy to forget
the deceived dynamics.
How do I play in most people lives in
ways that they may be able to recognize in
wheat last six stream, uh, consequences.
But like when you're a parent and
you have your kids going wild,
then suddenly you find yourself,
you know,
raising your voice and starting
to yell at them and not the cause.
I mean there's a time and a place sometime
is the right thing to do is to kind
of call them on their stuff in harsh ways.
But there's a difference between raising
your voice with any intent and raising
your voice because you are losing it
and you're getting overly emotional and
they're getting angry and Keats realize
it and they way leader you day we had a
CEO,
you are losing your stuff.
They will see how you are less of a
credible presence in their life that they
know can count on you that way because
you are a it in your own emotions and you
know they press the little button and
you go off sometime they'll press that
button because they enjoy seeing you
go off sometimes the, but you know,
the point is you're not
a good leader as a parent
and it's the same thing.
I mean my company now,
we work with businesses all over the
world and it's the same exact thing and I
teach the same exact thing. If you're
starting to get mad at your employee,
you're starting to get
mad at your subordinates.
If you're starting to
get mad at your boss,
what should you be doing as a good leader?
You should be detaching.
Taking a step back, I've told people,
hey, if you start feeling that way,
you stand up from the meeting table. Just
just, you know, no one's going to say,
Hey, what are you doing? You
just, you know, stand up,
stretch out, step back away.
These people are having a heated argument
and you start getting involved in it
instead of getting involved in it. Take a
step back. By the way, when you do that,
you look like a tactical genius because
everyone else has started to lose their
temper. They were starting to say
things that they shouldn't say.
And you're the one that's listening.
I just just covered a
book. Um, and, and just,
just like a little thing is if,
if there's, if you're talking,
I'm going to let you talk because if I
let you talk, I know twice as much as you,
I know everything that you know
and I know everything that I know,
so I'm going to win that
tactical situation. Um,
I want to come back to what you were just
saying to Angela about leadership as a
parent.
It ties into something he was talking
about a few minutes ago with like a police
officer who's panicking.
We were mentioning this on the car
ride over here about police shootings.
Like more often than not,
what you see is that they're the result
of incompetence. They're the result of,
um, uh, socially inept cop who
can't manage the situation.
And it's not an easy situation to manage.
You've got a potentially dangerous person,
you don't know them,
and maybe they're lightly
resisting you just verbally.
And you've got to take control
of that situation. Well,
unless you're an exceptionally competent
and confident person may be the only
tool you have to bring that person under
control is your baton or whatever it is.
And, um, you get the
impression in Vietnam,
especially once you get up to 68,
69 where you know,
they're starting to just throw junior
officers and right out of, you know,
ROTC and just throwing them
into combat. And you hear, uh,
stories about an
officer's getting fragged.
You start to hear stories about Cali
washed out ocs three, three times, right?
And you,
uh,
you get these people now into a situation
where you have a military unit that
recognizes they're incompetent
leadership and they're scared.
They feel incompetent
themselves as a unit. Um,
and you get them into a place where,
uh,
and maybe this is something that you can
contrast really well because you dealt,
you led primarily, uh, seals and marines,
right? Seals joke. It just hits you.
And you worked a lot with marine,
a lot with the marines and army soldiers
as well. Okay. Yeah. And just see,
mostly there's one battalion of
marines in inside Ramadi. Okay.
The three, eight marines. Awesome.
When you're dealing with, uh,
the American military today
and, and I know, I mean, um,
something that gets lost on
a lot of people is that, uh,
as highly trained and motivated and all
those things as our special forces are,
um, you know, they're very specialized.
You guys are, you know, trained for very,
very specific intense missions and stuff,
but you go pull an average ranger or
marine or something or infantry men, uh,
you put them in combat with
good leadership and that
is a unbelievably effective
soldier. I mean, American soldiers
today are all volunteer force.
These are incredibly well trained
and motivated people if you know,
as if they have the proper
leadership. Uh, when,
when you get back into a
situation like that with Vietnam,
where you get a whole unit
in that situation that,
that cops in where they're
in maybe a village,
they don't exactly know how to handle
this situation without resorting to lethal
force and they start to feel threatened
and everything runs off the rails.
It's, it's unrealistic to
expect just like, uh, you know,
you're happily married man,
and you don't want to cheat on your wife.
Then when you're off on a business trip,
uh,
after you've had a few drinks with the
coworker that's on travel with you, um,
it seems innocuous.
Maybe it's totally innocent at the time.
Don't go upstairs to the hotel to watch
a movie because if you get to that point,
you're just putting yourself in a terrible
position. Right. And, uh, and in an a,
in that military context,
the idea that all of the built up
momentum behind something like me lie,
the idea that you're going to get right
up to that moment on March 16th, 1968,
where the only thing that's stopping it
from happening is a few pounds a trigger
pull. That's the last bit of, you know,
that's your last opportunity to avert
this catastrophe is just that few pounds a
trigger pull. Good luck
with that. You know,
that's something that you
can't let it get to that point.
And that was something that, uh, and
then I'll let you guys take it over,
but I wanted to talk about something that,
it was fascinating to me that you
picked up on as soon as I said the word
establish dominance on
the streets or Ramadi,
you reacted against that and you're right.
That's incredibly important.
And it ties into what you
were just talking about,
about you would make people,
uh,
either back away from the situation or
stop looking down the sites of their gun.
Because when you're looking at a
person down the site, so your gun,
it's your framing of the situation and
you haven't put down their gun and now
it's just a person. It's not a target.
It's not anything like that. Uh,
if you got a bunch of people going into
Ramadi and they're thinking in terms of
our job is to go establish dominance
on the streets of this city. Well,
you're framing that in a way that under
the right circumstances could, uh,
you know,
lead to trouble.
And so framing it seems like
is what you're talking about.
And,
and I also want to make it perfectly
clear that if the soldiers,
marines seals that we work
with in the battle of Ramadi,
if they didn't dominate the
street as we move down it,
you know, we would be just be,
oh, we be killed. So there is,
the job is even harder than I made
it out to say to be because I don't,
I w I wouldn't want to use the
word dominate the city of Ramadi,
but you're damn right,
we're going to dominate the space that
we go into and we're going to do that by
being very,
very aggressive.
And so there is this fine line
and by the way, you'd go into a,
you'd kick a kick a door
in, in Ramadi, and there's,
there's gunfire in the
street that you're on.
You'd kick in a door and there would be
a mom and a dad and a couple of kids and
there'd be a normal
household with green grass.
And a soccer balls and that would happen.
That's what the city was filled with.
And so the fact that these guys were able
to flip that switch over and over and
over again was, was amazing.
And it's a, it's a testament to,
to the military forces that
we have and to the leadership.
I want to give equal credit to both.
But to your point about,
hey, you know me lie, these were draftees.
There was hundreds of thousands of
draftees that went over there and did an
incredible job. They were well
led, that stood up when people win,
when the wrong things were happening.
So this was a,
a horrible scenario.
Daniella, let's follow up on
that then. I mean, that's,
cause that's what's the
difference? Like what happens? Um,
you didn't get all the psychopaths in
the army and round them up into one unit,
right? Um, by all accounts,
the guys at me lie, uh,
talked to,
they were the type of people that when
the folks back in Kansas heard about what
happened,
they couldn't believe that little
Johnny would ever do anything like that.
Same thing at Sand Creek,
right? Same thing. And so
because you're right, we were talking
about this on the way to something today.
It is a for,
we have something like Abu Ghraib happens.
It's a terrible situation.
A lot of bad things went on there.
The idea though that an entire company
of American soldiers would go into an
Iraqi village and wipe
out 500 innocent people.
That is inconceivable today in the sense
that so many things would have to go
wrong and break down and degrade and
degenerate in the American military.
For that to have happened that it's just,
it seems like a completely
different moral universe and
you look at what the chain
of events that led to me lie.
It was those and if any
of those chain of events,
any anywhere along that chain of events
could have broken that whole chain.
Lieutenant Calley could've gotten killed
when the field and now you could add
someone else came in that was a better
leader and didn't have a Napoleon complex
and was able to stand up morally
to other people. There's,
there's so many things that
could have changed on that.
You know that could have changed
that whole scenario. The most,
the most powerful one
being a different leader.
It's the same thing at sand creek
different leader that that actually never
would have happened, never would have
happened and you that you do see that,
you know, you see all the guys on their
side lost soul like you 90 Mozambique,
they all agree with team.
Whereas all the guys we achieving United,
it's like clearly there's a leadership
element where the average guy in those
units,
he's heavily influenced by WHO's setting
an example for them and that sees one
of the scenes that interests me about
human nature that you know one of the
things cause we were discussing like
does that mean that human being,
you know one of the things too, we had
our loft, these are human beings just TV,
gold by nature and he's like,
no they are not evil.
Do Majority of people that are know there
are of course the exceptions that he's,
that whatever's mold percentage but the
majority of human beings are not evil.
The problem is that the majority of
human beings, Saturday, extremely easy,
lean for once,
like they're more alcohol and plus can
range in so many different direction that
and they're right.
Leadership Day will be awesome.
Human beings on the wrong leadership.
He's not that hard for them to start
sliding down it really dark direction.
So to me it kind of is a method
of weakness more than evil.
You know,
he's not that these guys are a complete
psychopath where you know you haven't
been there with diamond,
they are nice people and they yell to the
Old Lady Cross the street and yet the,
the Getty, why did, they
may have good intentions,
good intentions don't go
too far without crazy DC.
Pauline's throng willpower.
A lot of the qualities that allow you
to keep it as Gooding tension real and
they're heavy emotional thresher where
he doesn't all fly out the window and
it's like, I don't know
what happened. I just
lost my mind. Or Hey, they told me
that this was the thing to do when,
so I just followed orders.
You know where you have that integrity
to stay present in a crazy situation.
You're asking human beings to be kind
of extraordinary in those circumstances
because the ordinary human
being may go down a bad path.
So the antidote in some ways seem to
be to make yourself extraordinary,
to be, to be able to withstand a
kind of situation. And that's where,
and get a,
to lead our,
make a huge difference because so many
people would be like flexing the wind.
You know, if the wind is tilting
one way, they will go with it.
Even though knowing the
Stilton heavily the other way,
they'll also go that route and and
so that what he interests me is,
because while a few humans will always
choose a pretty massive upheaval side,
a bunch of humans can go either way.
What he's the shape,
the kind of human beings that we'll be
able to be a great leader or even just
for themselves,
even if they are dev,
nobody under them just day will make
choices that in an ideal scenario,
most human beings would want to make.
What does separate the guy who,
you know, he's sitting there
on on the couch saying, oh,
I would beat a guy and a guy
[inaudible] he's that guy.
I think one of the difficulties with that,
um,
is Jocko, you and Jordan Peterson
talked about this and um,
your podcast together.
Um,
you were talking about the book
ordinary men and how, uh, you know,
you've got a couple of guys,
group of guys there who are going to,
who are being ordered to do something
that's grotesque and it's not simply a
matter of like, you know, that's
a real good situation. If,
let's say you are a person of strong moral
character of just all the things that
you would want them to be.
You've got two conflicting moral
systems here because you have a duty and
obligation to your fellow soldiers who
are going to have to go do this one way
or another unless you revolt completely
and then you're betraying your country
and there's all these other things that
are brought into it that, you know,
that are moral things.
These are, you know, it's,
it's moral to not want to abandon your
friends and your colleagues to have to go
do the hard work that has to be done
so that you can go nurture yourself,
righteous sense of personal morality.
Or at least that's the type of thinking
that might go through a person's head.
Like,
no,
what right do I have to put my own
personal idea of what's right ahead of my
obligation as a soldier ahead of what
my country is telling me to do ahead of,
uh,
just being in there with all of my friends
and fellow soldiers and leaving it to
them. Like that's a moral
thing. And that is a,
that is something that you want
people to feel. Right. And I, and I,
and I wonder sometimes how much of these
situations are filled with people who,
um, you know, maybe 90% of them, the,
the vast majority that
aren't those few evil ones,
they're all kind of looking at each other.
Like maybe inside,
they don't necessarily
think this is right. Or B,
they don't want to be doing this but
they don't want to abandon their friends
and their friends are looking
at them thinking the same thing
and you just have this vicious
cycle in one of these things. Yeah.
And part of the problem there is the
human willingness to rationalize and make
justifications for oneself. He's
like, well, lean back again.
Cause you know when you look at
the principles that people hold,
like what they believe their philosophy
of life is and the way they behave,
even you match more
ordinary circumstances.
I mean you made the example of
the cheating husband, right?
How many people seriously believe that
monogamy is the right thing and you don't
cheat on your spouse? There will be lots
and lots and lots of people who say,
yeah, of course I believe in it. How
many people actually live up to it?
And it's like, come on man, that's not
nobody is shooting at you or nobody.
There are no, it's a match.
More mellow situation.
And people in many cases can to live
up to their ideals in very ordinary
circumstances,
let alone when you start pressing the
buttons and when the circumstances that
are no longer holding area.
But it becomes real panic time and
stress and all of that goes up.
So to me it's like you need to have almost
a maniacal determination to f discord
of Condo that you will hold up no
matter what happens. Like I use it as,
it's a joke,
but it is not a joke.
Like I use it for daily life as like to
me once I am very few more other roles
that are absolutes. But the ones that
are, there are no exceptions. So for me,
like if you give your word to somebody,
there are no exception.
It's like don't give your word unless you
are 110% sure you are going to keep it.
Don't, I don't mind. You know,
we can have a regular conversation
and you don't give your word,
but if you do give your award
to me there is no, oh sorry.
I didn't think in that situation
are there was that exception to me.
The only way you apologize is
a summer I style, you know,
you stick a knife in your belly and use
lives back and forth. That's how you say,
sorry. There is no exception to that.
It's almost as if, uh, you have the,
that those rules serve as Paul Stars.
When you're in a situation,
it's as chaotic as something like,
yeah.
Combat where you have to
have a few rules that,
I mean maybe there are arbitrary
but you'll die for him. Yeah.
Because when you're in the midst of a
situation that is completely outside the
realm of your normal experience, uh,
they give you reference points, you know,
they get,
they structure the situation a little
bit for you so you're not just lost in
chaos. There's some structure to it and
then you can evaluate the rest of the
environment relative to those hard
and fast rules that you've got.
Because in the situation,
you know when you're in me lie and you're
one of the people who's kind of on the
fence,
but now people are shooting,
that is not the time to have
this argument with yourself. No,
that's not when you're going to
figure it out. Yeah, for sure. Well,
this might sound really obvious and it is,
it's a very simple,
obvious answer to this really,
really hard question of how do you
prevent this thing from happening or who's
the kind of person that will stand up?
And the answer is it's actually,
it's quite simple. It's training
and education, it's training
and education.
And if people understand that these kind
of things can happen and they get put
in these pressers situations and they
get trained and they get debriefed on
mistakes that they made and they saw that
they got emotional and you train them
correctly,
well then you've got someone who gets
into a me lies situation and says to
themselves, wait a second,
we're not getting shot at
right now. Cease Fire. And,
and that was the most incredible thing
about that story is that's all it took
was a one leader to say, hey,
stop killing people. And they,
they literally stopped at that moment.
So training people and putting them in
these situations and educating them so
that they understand so that
they have pattern recognition,
training them so that they
can learn how to detach,
training them so that they can
control their emotions, training them,
that they can see when horrible
things are unfolding before them.
And then how the big, they can put a
stop to them. That is what is important.
And as you mentioned, Daryl, as the,
as the Vietnam War drove on, that the
training got less and less than that.
The officers were getting sent over
quicker and quicker and you're getting on
the job training and the
person that you're getting on,
on the job training from is a person
that's only been doing it for two and a
half months longer than you. And
that's, that's how these things occur.
So you have to invest in, in, in people
that are going to be in these situations.
And it's the same thing again.
I tell this to businesses all the time,
have you done, you know, on a
construction site, have you done a drill?
If you have a mass casualty,
w do you know what,
you know where you're going to
call in casualty evacuation?
Do you know we're getting
into what the air,
air flight are a life flight numbers?
Does anyone have the life flight number
here? Because if someone gets hurt,
you need to make that call. And do you
know what station you're going to call,
what helicopter you're going to call?
Do you know where they're going to land?
Why would you not run those things?
And if those things unfold and
you're not prepared for him,
you're going to fall apart.
And it's the same thing with these
ethical and moral situations where if you
don't understand what they are and you
don't understand what can go wrong,
you're gonna have,
you're gonna have a bad day.
And I felt he was,
but he didn't know what you brought up
a little bit ago when you said that are
steps along the way that long
before the crisis manifest itself,
there's that ability to recognize the
tiny little steps that are leading there.
Now when you look at the tiny thing,
it looks tiny.
It doesn't look like a big deal.
That's no crises that it's not a problem,
but he's that first step that's taken
you down that path and it's a lot easier
to stop it early then when crisis is on.
And so in that sense that does become
a training that does become a thing of
like how do you recognize the steps,
how do you work on it and you know you
are saying seeing so like even something
as magic I hey buddy to one second. Take
one second to breathe before you react.
Then seeing how you want to react is
the same thing that applies everything.
It applies to conversational.
When people are people you care
about maybe are getting you angry.
Do you really want to respond right
away or maybe take 30 seconds to take a
breath, then decide how you
want to respond. You know,
and I think he's like to me is we are as
silly as that he is because you don't,
clearly war and [inaudible] are very far.
You will.
You've ever seen so many ways but
to me as being one of the seat,
if I didn't go to it's,
I guess you're right,
but I guess to me has
been one of the most,
and for giving me or ours that added I
ever had poutine front of me was seen our
why or react under extreme stress
when you haven't slept for two days.
When somebody is throwing a fee to that's
completely unjustified when and said
that he's like, yeah, you have a little,
the good reasons to be mad by
really this is how you respond,
this is how you will react to a four
year old kid was just being a 40 year old
kid and you get all emotional and do
study island and suddenly like 10 Saquon
seemed to me blow it up. I see myself
from the outside and I'm like, um,
every scene that I despise in this moment,
you know that man right there that's
responding their way as all the reasons as
older. I can see why that hasn't met
that you still don't do it, you know,
and radar than just being like,
okay, let's wait for myself.
I'm a horrible human being. I
discovered that. He's like, okay,
what can I do now to get the or
next time you got real world world
training,
right?
Because now you recognize the situation
and now you don't let it happen anymore.
Exactly. You know, I had, I was talking
to you guys earlier, we, I hit it,
my first deployment to Iraq,
we went and hit a target and,
and it sounds almost like, you know,
like what you'd imagine in a movie.
We'd get handed a map then on the map
and to be a city block and Baghdad and
there'd be a red x on one of the
buildings and that's all I needed. Oh,
you want me to go hit that red x?
Cool.
We'll go hit that red x and one
night we went and hit, you know,
the building with the red x on it.
And when we hit the target,
it was like the most normal
family you could ever imagine.
And as we started talking to them and
we had our interpreter get in there and
figure out, you know, hey, do you know
who this person is? Were like, yeah,
he lives two doors down. Oh, okay.
And so then I went back and eventually
said to myself a question that if I
wasn't, if I had more experience, I would
have asked this question for me. I said,
Hey, I've got a question. Who put
that red x on that building and why?
And as I pulled the string
on it, it, you know,
it was one of those things where they
had gotten some Intel, which, you know,
I won't talk about where it came from,
but it was, it was intel that, you know,
put it in that general vicinity and
they like pick the center of the general
vicinity.
There's the center of the genitals
and either they will put the x and no
followup. And so I always taught
that as something, hey guys,
make sure you know who's giving
you this intelligence. And that's,
that's the case that happened to me. Lie
where the f the person on the, no one,
no one at the platoon said,
hey, whoa, hold on a second.
Who's who's confirming that
this is 100% VC in this village?
Our hunch, you're telling me
this is 100% VC in this village.
That's what we're saying right now.
Who's talking, who's saying that?
I want to talk to that person.
And that's another thing I talk
about all the time is you don't,
as a leader, you don't want
to be surrounded by yes men.
You don't want to be surrounded
by yes men. And you know,
we're talking about the horrors of
Vietnam War and I'm reading another book
right now and there's a platoon
commander and his guys are going there.
They're rotating between three locations
and two of the locations are not too
bad. The other locations is
a nightmare. It's, it's, it's
Vietnam War. Stereotypical,
it's booby traps,
snipers and indirect fire.
They never see the enemy.
They just never see the enemy.
And all they do is they go out there
on patrol and they get blown up,
they get shot, they get mortared and
they never see the enemy and the guy,
the guys are getting wounded or killed.
And
okay,
as you think about that,
I would,
I would pray that if I was the company
commander or the battalion commander,
that that platoon commander would
come to me and say, Hey Jocko,
this is stupid.
Let me tell you how many people we've
lost so many time and the other,
the platoons of lost. And let me
tell you what we've gotten out of it.
We've got nothing out of it and we,
we need to stop this or we need
to find a better way to do it.
If you want to send us in there, let us
set up a strong point. Let us set up a,
a bunkered position and we'll stay in.
We'll observe,
but us just walking around in
there waiting to get blown up,
makes no sense whatsoever.
Please, let's do something else.
And as a leader you have to
have the open mind to say, okay,
I thank you, I appreciate that
feedback. What are your suggestions?
You've been in the area of operations.
How do you recommend we do it?
And whenever I hear these stories of
guys that get put in really terrible
situations in the military,
it, it sickens my heart.
Because what you need is a culture inside
any organization. The military, yes,
but any organization of people to raise
their hands and say, Hey, wait a second,
this is stupid. Hey, wait a second.
Do I not see an American flag on that
Indian reservation with a white piece flag
underneath it and wait, wait, hold
on. Stop. Why wait, wait, stop.
And that takes moral courage.
It takes training and it takes a culture
inside an organization to stop people
in question what they're doing.
And it takes a certain level of
detachment that you were talking about.
It absolutely takes detachment.
You know, it's like, uh,
you were saying about like dealing
with a four year old or something.
Like when you're in the middle
of it. Yeah, it's seems normal.
It seems like the way to behave and it's
only when you step back and say, well,
you know,
uh,
one of the things about human beings are
great strength I suppose is that we're
supremely adaptable creatures.
I was talking to a psychologist one time,
used to work for the State Department
and he would, uh, he worked in
Africa for awhile. He talked about,
he was telling me some of the stuff that
he would encounter whole villages, um,
where every woman had been raped 10 times,
uh,
over the years where kids in this village,
she had watched their parents killed.
Just horrifying stuff.
And my question to them at the time,
cause he was a psychologist,
uh, was, I mean,
how are these people not just completely
blown out with Ptsd and everything
else?
Like how are they functional at all
given what we know about Ptsd and how it
does function under circumstances
that are far less severe than that.
And that's what he said. He said,
you'd be surprised. Humans are very,
very adaptable into them.
This is their environment.
And that can work the other
way too though. You know,
that can work in the
direction of, uh, the,
in the new Ken Burns Vietnam documentary,
which is just,
I don't know if you've watched it yet.
Uh,
the progress I think the
first two episodes. Okay.
So one of the ones you're coming
up on, uh, the name of it is,
this is what we do and it starts out
talking about this get new recruit and he
shows up to this place and like the
first thing he sees when he gets to a,
the base cities at,
it's not a mask or anything like that,
but it's just sort of a, you
know, a Vietnamese prisoner or,
or a captive being led along by,
you know,
a corporal or something and he's just
being rough with them and kind of push
them along and doing stuff that
clearly is outside of regulations.
And this new guy shows up and he's like,
Hey,
like you supposed to be
doing that or whatever it is.
And the first thing he hears when he gets
over there, his kid, this is Vietnam,
this is what we do.
And he said that their whole rest of
the time that he was there when he saw
something he didn't like when he was
doing things that he wasn't sure about,
he just repeated in his head, this
is Vietnam, this is what we do,
this is what we do. And after awhile
he didn't have to repeat it anymore.
After a while, that was his environment.
And you know, it reminds me,
I used to have these recurring dreams.
I probably shouldn't share
this on the air, but, um,
I used to have these recurring dreams. I
still have him every once in a while. Uh,
the details and the setting differ,
but um,
it'll be something like the dream starts
and I'm in like a helicopter say and
I'm flying around like a city like la
or wherever and I'm just shooting people
like grand theft auto. It's just like a
video game Tryna Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
And I'm going through
and I'm doing all this.
Sometimes there's people down there,
I know my friends and
stuff and it's just all,
it seems just like I'm in a video game.
And then the way the dream goes,
is it a certain point after
a few minutes of this,
all of a sudden it hits me what
I'm doing and I look around and I,
it's almost as if I wake up in
the dream and I'm like, oh my God,
like I'm killing all these
people. What, what am I doing?
But at the time it was completely normal.
It seemed exactly like this is just what
I should be doing or anything like that.
And that's something that I think that is,
well it's why you told people stop looking
down the barrel of your gun. You know,
you got to step back and be able to get
that distance so you can change your
frame. And again, with the proper training
and the proper education,
you will know as a leader that
that behavior will escalate,
that behavior will escalate.
And if you allow it to happen,
it will continue to get worse.
And so it starts off,
and I've read all kinds of books about,
about Vietnam,
especially about Vietnam, where it
starts off, it starts off with, hey,
the villagers are, we kind of know them,
everything's cool, give them lollipops,
but then you know, one of
our guys dies and then, well,
we're not getting lollipops.
As a matter of fact, we're,
we're kicking the kids away and,
and it, it only escalates to their,
and it escalates to
murder and it escalates.
Or I should say this,
it can escalate.
It doesn't automatically escalate because
all it takes is someone to step in and
say, Hey, no, that's across the line. But
you know what? You want to slap a guy.
I get it, I get it. But that's the line.
Anything once, you know, one
thing that we used to say,
and I used to tell my guys
once the cuffs are on somebody,
so once we get somebody
zip-tied it's over,
but you do what you gotta do to get a
guy under control. Once there's uptight,
it's done. And now they're, they're,
they're getting taken care of and
you, you treat them firm, but fair.
That's it. And so those lines, you,
you have to draw them and you have to
hold the line as a leader because things
start escalating.
You know,
the thing that you were asking
me about earlier about the, the,
the Chechen war and the Russians
against the Chechens and it's,
they didn't, they didn't hold
the line with the little things.
And that when you lose that discipline,
even up on the smaller things,
well eventually then you don't have
the discipline on the bigger things.
Can you go overboard
with that? Yes, you can.
I can hold the discipline so hard on the
little things that no one listens to me
on the big things.
That's why leadership is hard because
there's a dichotomy there that you have to
balance. You can't be freaked out
because, you know, you didn't,
you didn't blouse your boots when you
were supposed to, but at the same time,
if I start to let too many things
slide well it will escalate.
And it seems like maybe
with things like that,
a lot of people who were civilians,
they, they laugh when I see in movies or,
uh,
you know,
TV shows or something about how soldiers
in combat are still expected to groom
themselves.
They're still expected to take care of
themselves and comport themselves in a
military way.
And what I tell him a lot of the times is,
and maybe you can confirm this because
I don't really know what I'm talking
about, but it is that, uh, you
know, my, my feeling on, uh, on,
on why that stuff is so
important is that you can't have,
uh, you know, you can't have Iraq in
the sectarian war and all the stuff,
the storm that's going on around them,
you can't have that become the
environment to which they're adapting the
environment to which they need to
be well adapted as the u s military.
That's their environment.
That's what they're focused on,
following these rules
and behaving in this way.
And then when that's their environment,
they can go into these
places and do their jobs.
If they get in there and start reacting
to what's going on around them.
Because I mean, you then you can tell
a guy talking about going native,
native, you know, once a it's
apocalypse now, you can tell a guy, uh,
once the cuffs are on.
Uh, but you know, if,
if I was talking to a family yesterday
and this is the guy that just cut their
heads off, well, I mean, you know,
you,
you can't have,
you can't put yourself in a situation
because it does make sense to beat the
shit out of that guy.
It does make sense to put a bullet
in his head when the cuffs are on,
like from a, even from a moral
standpoint in certain ways like that,
you can justify that, you know? Um,
and so that's why you can't be reacting
to whatever it is that's going on.
And it sounds like that's
kind of what you're saying.
Yeah. And there's actually an interesting
dichotomy there as well, because
you, you need to follow the rules, right?
Because if I told, if the
three of us decided, hey,
we're going to go on this village raid
and we're all going to use our morals as
our guide, well we have three
different scenarios. You're,
you just admitted that you'd be execute
and somebody that was already handcuffed,
uh, who knows what you'd be doing, you
know, I don't even want to know. Right.
And so, so we were all over
the map, right. Maybe you're,
maybe you're saying you're,
you're not even going to,
I don't even want to handcuff anyone
cause you think that's too offensive and
I'm somewhere in the middle. Whatever
the case may be, we're all over the map.
So I would always tell the guys,
look, you need to do what is legal,
what's legal?
But then the paradox of that is sometimes
what you can get away with the legally
still isn't the right thing to do.
And that's again,
that's why there's a dichotomy
between those two. Between,
do I follow the rules exactly. Or I
mean, you know, look at, look at me.
I look at Sand Creek that
my boss told me to shoot.
This guy told me to shoot
this three year old baby.
My boss told me to do that. I'm,
should I be following orders?
Is there a threat that I don't know
about? You know, these days, you know,
I've heard a lot of stories now the
guys that that took down Mozel right?
The,
the enemy was sending,
surrendering children to come
and surrender to coalition
forces and they would
be strapped with a ID vests,
suicide vests,
and over and over and over again, it was
our US military, you know, especially our,
our explosive ordinance disposal folks
and that we're going in disarming these
bombs on these kids.
But yeah,
how do you feel after you see two or
three of those little kids get killed plus
two or three EOD guys get killed and
now you're going to fight those guys and
they want to surrender.
That's a very challenging thing.
And if you don't maintain discipline,
it's a slippery slope.
And it's funny because we're saying
to seeing said the same time,
which sound contradictory and yet that's
life that on one end you need to have
this super strict rules. They are not
going to bend under circumstances.
And on the other end,
your thing that you rightly point out
too is the fact that Rhea leadership is
also the ability to think on your feet.
And no two situations are alike.
So the rule for loin approach,
while he may save you from some of the
worst abuses is not always necessarily
the right thing.
And there,
there's also the time when we all lost
follow the rules except when we don't
because that's the one
time when it's correct.
And that ability to make the
right call at the right time,
that's what make you an extraordinary
already in our human being.
We're just sort of in debates are
popping off at the mouth today. Yeah,
we sort of take for granted that the
whole, um, I was just following orders.
Question was settled at Nuremberg.
It was not settled at all.
That's an incredibly complicated
question for just the reason you were
describing. You know, uh,
somebody who worked at a Nazi death camp,
um,
you know,
they didn't make 10,000 independent
decisions to kill somebody.
Uh, they made one decision that their own
personal moral compass was going to get
outsourced to the state and that they
were going to do their duty and follow
their orders.
They made that decision once and now,
once you've made that decision and
you've outsourced your moral compass,
which again,
under most circumstances that might be
the thing that keeps you from doing the
wrong thing now might be the thing that
keeps me from executing that. You know,
I'll kind of guy.
But when the institutions themselves
start to get warped or if you're in, even,
even if the institution is an individual
unit or something, you know, uh, it's,
uh, I can't remember where
I heard it, but there's a,
some zoologist or somebody who
pointed out to him that, uh,
he had asked why zebras have black and
white stripes when the grass is gold
colored in yellow and they
don't blend into that at all.
Clearly Tigers can see that.
And he pointed out to him that that
camouflage isn't to blend into the
environment. That camouflage
is to blend in with each other.
They blend with the herd.
And so the Tigers have a
difficult time tracking down,
like in focusing on an
individual. And uh, they, oh,
they figured that out because they
wanted to try to put ear clips on them or
something to track these things around.
But they noticed every time they put
something identifiable on one of them,
the Tigers would kill it.
And it was because now they had something
to focus on it. So, and that's, you know,
I'm not making a literal
evolutionary comparison here,
but there's an interesting like,
just sort of analogy,
which is this instinct to
blend in with the herd.
There's just their safety there. There's
a sense of security there and there's,
there's virtue in for fitting a certain
amount of your personal judgment to the
group to which you have obligations.
That's a good thing under most
circumstances. You know what I mean?
At least in a lot of
circumstances. You know, that's
what duty is. That's what, um,
you know, just fulfilling your obligations
to your people or you, you, you,
your unit or something. Like, who are you?
Especially if you're an 18 year old
kid who just got out of high school and
you're over there and you're in a
situation where you've got, you know,
like in me lie, you've got
officers, you've got uh, you know,
not just your immediate officer,
but it seems to be being reinforced
by your captain above, you know,
your company commander at the
time, and me lie, there was a,
there was a major general in a helicopter
observing, buzzing around that place.
And so, you know, you're in a situation
where you say to yourself like,
who am I to say that what's
going on here is wrong?
It seems wrong to me because of what
I learned from my Mama or whatever.
But you know what, what does that mean?
I've got a captain, I've got a lieutenant,
I've got my sergeant's, I've got this
major general in the air. And you know,
maybe I'm wrong, maybe this,
you know, I just got here
four months ago. This was my,
this is a Charlie company's first major
combat operation is it really hadn't
made contact,
direct combat with the enemy.
And this is the first time any of them
have seen combat for the most part.
And I think it's uh,
um,
there's certainly a certain amount of
weakness that's involved like you were
talking about.
But I also think there's a certain amount
of moral confusion that happens and
that's, that's, there can't
be that kind of confusion.
Like that is where leadership
has got to take over.
I can add another layer of complexity
to this. Okay. So, so first of all,
I do think that the,
well Napoleon said,
if you execute an order
that you know is wrong,
and when he was talking about he's not
talking about something that moral,
he's talking about,
if I do something where a bunch of my men
get killed because the general said to
do it and I do it, I'm
culpable. So that's,
that's pretty clear that if your boss
tells you to do something that you know is
gonna in Napoleon's case it was getting
a bunch of your guys killed then,
then you say no. And if you do it,
you're called Bobo for what happens.
You could say the same thing.
If,
if I get told to do something
that's morally or ethically
wrong and I do it well,
guess what? Then I'm
responsible for that. What?
What becomes a little bit complicated to
me or adds another layer of complexity
is this,
if I'm going to sand creek and I'm with
Chington and he or she havington and he
says, um, hey, we're going to go there
and we're going to execute this and we're,
we're, we're going to kill
these guys. We're going to,
we're going to conduct a raid
and I don't believe in it.
Okay? So I say, you know
what? I don't believe in it.
I don't think it's the right thing to do.
I think that we've made enough peace
with them. We've caused enough problems.
That's their land. I'm not going, okay,
so now you don't go because you
didn't believe in the mission.
Well now who's out there
conducting the mission?
Everyone that's going out there to
conduct the mission is people that are
compliant with what he's saying.
So you would be,
you would be morally a better
person if you said, okay,
I'm going to go ahead and do this.
Because if I don't,
I know it's going to be someone that's
totally compliant with Shillington and
I'd rather be there to at
least spare some of the people,
which we know people did.
And so there's,
there's a little complexity. No, I talk
about this in the business world too.
People say, my boss told me to do this
and, and I, I think it's a bad idea.
I don't think we should do it. Okay, so
are you going to get put off the project?
Are you going to get
pulled to a different,
a different department where you
no longer can take care cause you,
you listen too hard on my people, I'm not,
I refuse to do this. Okay, that's fine.
You refuse to do this.
I'll put someone in there that won't
refuse and you no longer can protect your
people and your people
in a worse situation.
So there's organization is degraded whole
organization. So you raise your hand,
you make your protest. But
sometimes you've got to say, okay,
I've made my protest and I understand
that you're still wanting me to do this
and even though I think
it's the wrong thing to do,
I'm going to proceed down the path because
I'd rather me be able to mitigate as
much of this problem as I can. Then have
somebody that's just going to do, do,
do this to the fullest extent
that you would want them to do.
So there's another additional
complexity there that it gets involved.
Absolutely.
Cause sometime as you said,
just the nine you're just
making yourself feel better.
But the reality is that
plan is going to go ahead.
You are the only thing that's
standing in the way of that plan.
Going to the 100 percentile,
you can bring it down to 50 you know
he's still going to feel out I go,
you're still going to feel part of
something you don't want to be part of.
But the only thing you do by refusing is
patting yourself on the back and say am
I in all tomorrow guy? It's like,
yeah, but no, cause you know,
it's like the thing is you can use
that power in that situation too for
something that he's better
than if you just, uh,
look at herself in the mirror saying
how great you are by not doing it.
And in fact that's what it was pitching
Canadian bill about the Sun Click story.
Silas soul, you know, they,
he's told right before you
don't want to stay home.
Nobody's forcing you to just stay home.
Don't be part of it.
And soul and Kramer and some of those
guys say, no, we want to be there.
We want to be there to observe. We may
be able to make the choice on this spot.
And uh, and he makes a huge
difference right there.
My feeling on it, just sort of looking
at it all from the outside is that,
and especially in a counterinsurgency war,
that without strict military discipline
and strong leadership that abject
savagery is gravity will take you there.
That's where things
will head on their own.
Unless you are supremely
focused on discipline and
leadership and education and
those kinds of things
that you don't have to,
you don't really have to ask the question,
how can this kind of thing happen?
The real question is how does this
not happen all the time, right?
How is it that American
soldiers in Iraq and uh,
you know, you go into Iraq
and they're seeing, uh,
maybe,
maybe husbands and fathers that they
spoke to the previous day that they know
are innocent,
not part of the fighting and they see
his wife beheaded and him with a power
drill hole on the side of his head.
How our American soldiers not going and
executing reprisal attacks against these
people all the time.
How has it not just completely getting
out of hand like that to me is by far the
more interesting question. I don't have
to ask myself how is it that you know,
somebody went in and shut
up, you know, the, that,
that the house of the person
who did something like that.
That's an easy question
to answer. And, and the,
the much more interesting one is how it
doesn't happen all the time and it, it,
it seems like it's, it has
to be institutional. It
can't come down to like, uh,
you know, institutional culture, right.
I'm relating it to their sense of personal
identity and social identity with the
group that this is not who we
are. Um, that if I do this,
it's not going to win me any,
uh,
any Kudos from my teammates
or anything like that.
There you're going to look at that as a
betrayal because I'm bringing dishonor
upon us because this is
not what we're about.
And they have to be able to look at it
that way. And if they don't know that,
if they don't know that by
doing something like that,
they're going to, uh, you know, they
want to blend in with the group.
They want to be accepted by the group.
They want to be looked at as
somebody that can be relied on.
And that has to mean following the
rules and doing the right thing.
Yeah. Well, did Danielle, you poured it,
pointed this out earlier. You, you said,
well this seems like it's just the
communications aspect is so important and
that's 100% right. So
as we all know, the, the
strategy in the Vietnam War for
America was to kill more of them.
Then they data,
Vos and drop more bombs on
them and eventually they'll
just break just a war of
attrition. And, and so the,
the strategy was get rack up as many kill,
count as high kill count as you
possibly can. So that's the messaging.
That's the messaging.
So when that's the messaging,
that's the messaging in,
in Iraq,
they were very clear about,
hey, we're here too. We're,
we're not an occupying force.
We're here to liberate these people were
here to secure the populous and make
sure that they can have a free country.
That's the messaging.
So does that messaging always
make it down to the front lines?
Know that's why we do have
incidents where Thi, you know, bad,
horrible things happen.
Absolutely.
But it is about the messaging and it is
about everyone understanding why they're
doing what they're doing,
what their mission is,
what is what is right and what is wrong.
And you can be educated on that legally,
hey,
you're not allowed to do this. You
can do that, but you can't do this.
And then the other point that
you made, which is, well,
you said you got to be able to manage
people in a time of crisis as a leader,
but more important. And you, you actually,
you actually asked a really complicated
question and then answered it yourself.
And you did that like three times.
And that one is fear of conversation
that you had with yourself. Yeah, yeah.
Is, is you said, you know,
you gotta be able to manage people in
these pressure situations and then you
added that. But what you really
need is culture. And you're right,
because you're not going to be there.
The leader is not, I wasn't with my,
all my elements on the
battlefield all the time.
They were out there all the time
without me all the time without me.
They were the ones that had to understand
what they could, what they couldn't do.
They were the ones that had
to make those hard decisions.
They weren't calling my snipers, didn't
call back to me and say, Hey Jocko,
I see this with this guy.
They didn't even ask their platoon
commanders that they didn't ask anyone.
They knew what the rules of engagement,
where they knew what our strategy was.
They understood. And one of the
things that I told them, you know,
speaking of rules of engagement, so
our rules of engagement was, you know,
several page legalees document written
by some lawyers in Washington DC or
wherever.
And you know,
I've got kids in my platoon
that are 20 2122 years old,
you know,
high school graduate and they came in
the seal teams like I did by the way.
And so they're looking at a legal
document like that. Does it,
it doesn't mean anything to them.
You know,
my rules of engagement for them or is
it very simple? Make sure that people,
you're killing our bad. You make sure that
people, you're killing her bad and why.
And then I explained to
them why that was important.
And the reason why that was important
was because the day that some civilians
brought a headless body that it had
taken a 300 win mag round to the head and
their head was gone and they said,
this was our mom,
or this was our school teacher,
or this was our neighborhood doctor,
and one of your snipers killed them and
they would figure it out. It was us.
First of all, our operations
would get shut down. So selfishly,
we don't want to get
our operations shutdown,
but more important than the
selfish reason. If that happened,
we would leave all the
soldiers and marines that we
were working with on a daily
basis that we are providing Overwatch for.
We've leave them without the support that
we had committed to give them because
we weren't allowed to operate anymore
because we weren't being discriminatory
enough with our fire.
So the culture is so important.
People understanding why they're doing
what they're doing is so important.
And if you don't get that messaging
into your point, DNA, Daniella,
if you don't get the
communication correct,
then you're going to end
up in a world of hurt.
And to point you just made the,
make sure the people you key or bad,
he's such a, I think about a
day or so few words, right?
You say teen lake, very, very few words.
And yet he's so centered
because you look at,
not all the San [inaudible] core me lie,
but look at even like half of the,
you know, when the Nazi
seeing vade the Soviet Union.
And then when the Red Army does the
counter and they start invading Germany,
both armies do horrible seeings
to one another civilian.
And the idea is, well, the Nazis did
to our people. So we did it today.
Our swell that ma'am,
that you are shooting in the head at it.
She had nothing to do with what
happened to your people. She's,
she's not the Nazi soldier would deed it.
She's not the bad one just because
she's from the same nation.
Are you kidding me? That's not,
that doesn't make her a bad person.
And I think that's part of the problem.
We group identity that soft and that's
why I stayed with types are dangerous
because you start grouping individuals
into this mental category you may have of
like those guys are bad.
That individual only share some physical
characteristic with the other one they
share maybe the or even are related,
but they are not the same person.
You know the date I haven't
made the same choices.
They haven't committed the same action.
So the fact that you three told the
Cheyenne the same or you decided to retool
the Vietnamese the same or the
Germans the same or the Russians,
that's where every single is wrong because
you're are not making sure that the
person you're hurting is
the bad one is not the one.
There's no a Vange dared.
They are not the same people.
And so and yet it happens
over and over again.
Where people fall into this
idea of group mentality is,
well I couldn't catch that guy back.
He's one of their group is I know man.
There are individuals that
are involved that are not,
there is no collective guilt off. It's
kind of the same reason why, for example,
federal reasons strike as I saw all fall
in every possible way because you're
now going against the guide.
I have a grievance against.
You're going against the
guy from the same nation.
It's like that has nothing to do
with one another. You know, they're,
I feel like sometimes group identity,
it's one of those double edged swords,
right? Because on one hand there's a
side of it that we mentioned earlier.
Maybe your loyalty to your group and not
wanting to bring dishonor upon them if
that's the culture is what keeps you
from putting a bullet in the head of the
guy you just cuffed prep. Um,
you might be able to appeal to a,
um, you know, you can say to people, hey,
we're Americans and this is not how we
behave and you're appealing to their
group identity there,
you know, and uh, that
nobody's saying it's a double edge sword.
That is a case in which you
are using group identities
for as the good guys. And,
and granted,
yeah,
it may not be that every single one
from.com three really feed that idea by
you're putting a nice ideal and they
are encouraging people to live up to it.
That's all that IDD furnace from.
While it's similar in dynamics too damned
bad guys and flagging everyone into
dad group,
where do you know that that person really
fit that stereotype at [inaudible] at
all? How did you make clear to your
men, uh, when you said, you know,
make sure that people you're killing or
bad that they understood what was meant
by that.
It is,
well there's first of all there,
there are specifics and the rules of
engagement and one of them is called clear
hostile intent, hostile
actor, hostile intent,
which means this person has to be doing
something actively that's going to cause
it cause a negative impact.
Now
you can tell which people are bad.
You can tell when they're starting to do
something that's hostile actor hostile
intent. You can tell and these
guys, you know, my guys would, they,
they knew,
they would err on the side of like,
I'm going to make sure that this person
is doing something bad. But you know,
we had some decent uh,
arguments about the rules of engagement.
I had some decent arguments about the
rules of engagement off the chain of
command because the rules of engagement
were applying to all of Iraq and Ramadi
was not like the rest of Iraq at
this time in 2006. And you know,
if you've got someone
that is for instance,
observing a location with binoculars,
right? If you're observing,
if you're in Baghdad and you're look
looking at a location with binoculars,
you're gathering intelligence, which
is, which, which could be considered,
which is not considered a
hostile act. It's, it's, it's
the intelligence gathering.
You might suspect the person being bad,
but there's,
there's no way to prove that in Ramadi.
If you saw somebody that was looking
with binoculars at friendly forces,
they weren't gathering intelligence,
they were absolutely
coordinating attack and attack.
And that is a group that
is a big difference because
that is a hostile act and
it's damn sure hostile
intent. And so, you know,
those are the kinds of things that I
would discuss up the chain of command and
we would provide them the
resources. You know, it's,
I talk a lot about um,
playing the game, right?
Like if my boss tells me to do something,
I'm going to play the game.
I'm going to try and do it. And, and,
and occasionally I'll get
the question of like, well,
what if you get told to do something
that you really don't want to do?
What if you've got told to do something
that you didn't, that you were posed to,
right?
What if you got the order to go to the
me Lai massacre and you got the order?
Well, yeah, it's, I know I'd
say no. And first of all,
that doesn't happen the closest.
The closest example I have to that
happening was for me in Ramadi,
we had been told that we had to take a
certain number of Iraqi soldiers with us
on every operation we conducted because
we were trying to turn the war over to
them.
And so they needed to get out there and
do operations and they were telling us
they were putting this, this rule all
over every American unit and Iraq.
You needed to have an Iraqi
face on every operation.
So what did the Americans do? What
did, what did the American units do?
What they did was they say, okay, yeah,
we're going to take our platoon of 40
guys and we're going to take to Iraqis
with us, and there's your Iraqi face.
Well, that doesn't move the work forward.
They were obeying the rules.
So the,
the senior leadership figured this out
and said, no, you guys are playing games.
Here's the new rule for every,
and I forget what the number was.
They made a ratio for every seven
Americans that you have or for every one
American you have to have, you have,
you have to have seven Iraqi's are,
there were some number,
some ratio. And in Ramadi,
some of the units of Iraqis that we
were working with only had 18 guys or 17
guys.
And so that would have been me sending
my guys in the field with two or three
seals only, which sending, if you've got,
if you're going to go into a
bad area and you're going to,
who are you going to send?
Because you want to have a radio man,
you want to have a medic, you want to
have a guy that can call for fires.
You want to have a leader and
you want to have a couple heavy,
heavy weapons guys, that's, that's six or
seven guys right there. Minimum, right?
And so when the chain of command told
me, hey, you got to do this ratio,
I looked at the ratio and then, and I
said, hey guys, uh, in Ramadi, that's,
that's not a good idea and here's why.
I'm not going to send my guys in the field
without a corpsman or without a radio
man, without a Jay Tac or without
a machine gunner. I'm not,
I'm not going to do that.
And you know what they said?
They said, that makes sense.
Chocolate, you proceed. Like if
you articulate yourself correctly,
then you can get your point across.
Now head they said to me,
hey listen, no, you're
only allowed to do this.
Well then I would have objected further
up the chain of command and I would not
have put my guys at risk to do
something that didn't make sense.
I'm not not going to do
it. Um, and, and again,
that's what I always encourage military
people, but not as military people,
business people.
If you're the CEO of a company and you've
given some directive that you don't
understand the full depth of the directive
that you've given and your frontline
somebody,
somebody in your front lines realizes
that's going to have a hugely negative
impact on your company.
Do you want them just to follow orders?
You absolutely don't
want them to followers.
You want them to raise their hand and
say, hey boss, this doesn't make sense
and thing. Yeah. You said about, yeah,
you don't want to surround yourself
with yes men, which makes perfect sense.
Then again,
eats.
It's one of the sinks where you really
need to have work on yourself because the
reality is that most people have an eagle.
Most people don't like to be told,
hey boss, sorry about that. Doesn't
sound right. He's like, what do you mean?
You know? There's that reaction
is like standing their pride,
which of course that were old badness
decision shall making started going,
but he's a very normality. Actually,
you know what I beat? He's like,
most people have to one degree or
another and ego and his speech. Shelly,
if like your guy maybe phrase
it, maybe they are right, right.
The makeup falling toward,
they are pointing to something
in your plan and doesn't work,
but they phrase it in a way
that's kind of blonde, so a,
you don't like being watched.
The, you don't like the tone.
By that point, even though their
content is perfectly correct,
you're not eating it because he's like,
you have a better, I don't like you first.
They are crazy size we and then you
are going about it with that tone.
The guy is just saying seeings
plainly how they are. Maybe it's not,
it hasn't had a bad tone is
just not cardinally knew.
Wayne likes lowly Jane saying,
Hey, let's see this way
and, and you know what a guy
in that, cause I get the,
I get that kind of question all the time
with all the companies we work with,
all got this guy and my,
my boss has a big ego and I can't
correct him because he just,
he just gets a fee. Well first of
all, when you just like you said,
if you've got a big ego and I
tell you that your plan is wrong,
I'm attacking a fortified position
and you're only going to bolster your
position stronger and so don't attack
that position instead of simple technique
that you can use is say,
hey boss,
I'm really not sure why we're using this
approach. Could you explain this to me?
Because I want to make sure that I really
understand what it is you want me to
do.
And it seems like if I do this right here,
it's going to cause this reaction and,
and I don't want,
I know you don't want that to happen,
so could you just give me a hand and
fully understanding what your plan is and
that way you're, you're, you're,
you're kind of massaging their ego a
little bit and it opens their mind and
that's all you have to
do is open up their ears.
That's the goal is just to open their
ears a little bit so that you can start to
have a conversation with them and so that
they can going back to the whole topic
of today so that they can see
you as a human being with a,
with an idea or an opinion that actually
matters as opposed to seeing you as
someone that's attacking their
ego and that ego thing. I mean,
if you think about the wars
that have been, you know,
we always talk about the wars
that are caused by religion,
but the wars that are caused by
ego or are also pretty severe.
And a lot of these incidents that we
talk about, these retaliatory incidences,
well,
who's going to be the first person to say,
you attacked my tribe and
I'm going to let it slide.
But that's, that's, that's a tough
person. That's a hard position to be in.
You're seen as weak. You're
seen as you know, vulnerable.
You're seen as someone that can
be pushed around. So there's,
that's a very delicate game that you have
to play and that causes problems with
that. That ends up, that's a
game that's so hard to play.
In fact, that most people,
or many people across the
span of time have said, no,
I'm not going to say that they did.
They drew blood.
We're going to draw more blood.
Yup.
And it
goes to what you were saying a second
ago to your people have to know that
you're going to ask those questions of
your leadership and that you're doing
that work because they got to trust you.
You know that way when Jocko
comes to him and says, hey guys,
I know this is gonna
sound a little bit weird,
but here's what we're doing and here's
who you're bringing with you and this is
what we're doing. They know that
if you're telling them to do it,
it's gotta be done.
That every discussion has been had
that every angle has been looked at,
that you've run it up the chain of
command and registered your objections if
they're there,
but they know that Jocko is not going
to send us out to do something like this
unless it simply has to be done.
And I get asked this question a lot,
well,
what do I do if one of my subordinates
has a question about the way I've planned
something and I don't have a good
answer? What do I do? Then I say, well,
what you do then is you listen to them.
You actually listened to what
they're saying because if, if,
if I've told you to do something and
you've then responded with some reason why
we shouldn't do that thing and I
can't explain away your reason,
then probably I'm wrong.
And, and as a leader,
this is another thing where our ego plays
a role as a leader. Our Ego says, well,
if I admit that I'm wrong to the troops,
they're gonna think I'm up there going
to think I don't know what I'm doing.
The opposite is actually true.
If I was in charge of youtube
and I presented you with
a plan and you guys came
back and today that plan's
not smart and I said,
shut up and do it the way I told you,
you don't respect me more,
you respect me less.
And if,
if I came to you two with a plan and said,
hey guys,
here's the way we're going to
execute this. And you say, Hey,
that's not a good idea. We should do
it a different way. And I say, okay,
well what do you recommend? And we come
together with a collaborative plan.
You don't think less of me as leader.
As a matter of fact,
you think more of me as a leader.
You think that I'm a humble guy that will
listen and take input. And by the way,
bonuses,
you all now have real,
true ownership of the plan
and we all feel good about it.
And when you guys go in the field,
you execute it to the utmost
of your ability because
it's something that you own.
It's amazing how everything
you're saying is,
it's as if you took a list of all the
traits of Lieutenant Calley at me lie and
literally just said,
do the opposite of all these things.
He was a guy who couldn't take criticism
from his men, 100% who asserted a,
you know, who pulled rank anytime,
anything like that happened. Uh,
who was a complete transparent yes man
to his captain above him who was just
never ask any questions. I mean, just
right down the line. And as a result,
his men had no trust in him so that
when they got into a situation that was
chaotic,
they felt like they were standing out
on the corner by themselves in a country
they didn't understand with
nobody looking out for them.
I don't want to say this in a way that
makes it sound like I'm trying to justify
anything they did,
of course not.
But you put men in a situation where
they feel like they're in complete chaos
and they happen to have automatic
weapons in their hands. Well,
if I find myself in a situation where
I'm completely overwhelmed by chaos,
that automatic weapons probably going to
start to look like the best tool I have
for structuring my environment.
Yeah, there's a, and, and obviously this
went way beyond that. Uh, years ago,
I forget how many years ago there
was a shooting in New York City, uh,
I think it was 38 rounds were fired at,
uh,
maybe a homeless person and unarmed
person. I forget the situation,
but there's a lot of people that
just couldn't believe that all these,
all these police officers shot
at this unarmed individual can.
Horrible situation. And again, I always,
I've always will say this like whenever
I talk about bad police shootings,
I been on ride alongs with cops.
I've done hits with cops.
It's a freaking hard job. And, and,
and I'm not a guy that like I've done
that a couple times here and there,
but go out on that beat every day and
deal with those scumbags of the world
every single day. And you're going to
have, it's going to be, it's the freedom.
It's one of the hardest jobs in the world.
That situation people to,
how the hell did that
happen? Well, there's,
there's a lot of tension in a
situation that emotions are high,
people are screaming,
we're not trained well.
Everyone is sitting there with
their slack out the trigger.
And when that first bang happens, it's
a, it's a chain reaction. That's one.
One of the situations that,
you know,
I would see with my guys
that was beautiful in Ramadi
was they wouldn't do that
if, if one of the snipers took
appointed shot at someone,
they would take the point of shot
and the others would hold fire,
check fire until, you know,
the, the situation either
evolved or, or deescalated.
But the,
the army was always quite impressed
with the fact that we would take really
surgical shots at bad guys and
there wouldn't be, you know,
massive amounts of collateral damage.
Again, sometimes it's unavoidable, but
maybe you can talk a
little bit about that.
Cause I think that's one thing that gets
really lost on a lot of people saying.
I think there's a lot of propaganda
that helps it get lost. You know,
there's no question that there's
been an evolution and um,
our values and our relationship to
these kinds of things over the years.
So you go back to something
like San Creek, 1864, uh,
there might not have been a whole lot
of people shedding too many tears over
what happened.
You get up to me lie and you know,
there's some controversy and there's
some, you know, there's a cover up,
all those kinds of things.
But once it comes out and it's laid
bare and the evidence is clear,
things had changed from 1864, and that,
that incident and a few, you know,
other incidents that were going on,
it made it out.
Or a few pictures that came out,
it turned people against the war.
They decided that this is not worth
putting our men in a situation where we're
going to be doing things like this. This
is not worth it. And you get up to today,
uh, in the Iraq war or
something like Abu Ghraib,
which is an unacceptable situation,
but we're talking about prisoner abuse.
That doesn't,
uh,
th th th that wouldn't cause the people
who were working in that prison five
years before that the Iraqis who
worked for Saddam, that wouldn't even,
you know, they, they wouldn't even make it
through their filter. Right. So, I mean,
what, what was going on there
with the American soldiers?
It was, it was not okay,
but it wasn't walking into a village
and mastering 500 people. It wasn't,
uh,
you know,
brutal torture in the same way that we
would think of what was going on before
we took control of that prison. And yet
our response to that in the military,
his response to it once it came
out was pretty dramatic. I mean,
was theirs and it was quick.
It didn't,
there was not as much of a delay
as soon as it comes out of theirs.
So there's a clear shift
that's going on there, if,
if even primarily from the standpoint of
it's just, it's a breach and discipline,
that's not how you behave.
Yeah. And, and,
and one of the things that I'd talk
about with my guys is because you got to
frame this right because you,
you know,
you mentioned earlier that if you had to
dealt with this person that had cut the
heads off of the three year
old girl yesterday and now you,
you had him cuffed and knew it was him,
that guy deserves a bullet, right? I, Hey,
I agree with you. That guy
deserves a bullet. The problem is,
well, number one, it's a
breakdown in discipline,
but to me more important and what I would
tell my guys is if we behave that way,
we have a significant chance of
strategically negatively impacting our war
effort. So I get that you
want to kill these bad guys,
but more important than us killing these
bad guys is us in winning this war.
And so if we run around doing dumb things,
we're going to have a negative
strategic impact on the,
and that was actually always the biggest
worry as a leader is you don't want to
have some, something happened
where you, you know, you,
you drop a bomb on the
wrong area or you know,
in a bunch of civilians get
killed or you know, you,
you don't want to have that thing happen.
That's a real,
and the effort and lengths that American
forces go to to prevent civilian
casualties is, is incredible. I don't
think most people have any idea.
No they don't.
They don't works.
And I think that's why of the
coolest things about creatine,
a certain methodology that people would
want to live up to the first time you
say it,
he may not be through,
he may be a wishful thinking that you
hired those people and you're not quite
there. But as people keep repeating
eighth and your, and again and again we'd,
the fact that your behavior doesn't
match your ideas more and more people we
keep working on trying to
actually build that thing.
They don't want to feel
that like hypocrites.
They actually want to
live up to that idea.
And that's one of the sinks were why is
sometimes people get turned off by when
you have these high minded id, I'll end
this very poor behavior. Or they're like,
oh, look at that hypocrisy. They,
Sadie's seeing Sunday domain it, well,
sometime when you say it long enough,
people actually do want to live up to
it and they do change their behavior.
So while the theory may not match
the practice, when you start,
if you keep at it long enough,
the practice may try to,
he inched closer to mention that
theory ideals, not a bad thing.
I mean, I, I, you can take it
to uh, uh, political context, right?
When people can point back at the United
States say before the 1960s and before
the civil war and point
to the Constitution and
declaration of independence in
these high minded ideas and people love
to be the cynical one that says, oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, but slavery and of course,
but this and that. And yeah, totally,
totally true. But the, the,
the conclusion to draw
from that is not that, uh,
the ideals don't matter or
that they're just on paper.
The fact that those ideals where there
was what allowed the civil rights
movement to eventually ups come
into being, that's what I, you know,
gave us the room. In fact, you could even
say that the thing we're talking about,
the same thing, uh, that gap
between ideal and reality.
One Way to talk about that is hypocrisy.
But at the same time, that gap,
that opening is,
that's the opening where people realize
that and say there is a gap between our
professed ideals and it makes room for
that of positive change. Right? I mean,
you can go back, uh, there was,
the Mongols were never ever going to give
up slavery because their moral system
didn't have room for that. Yeah. And so
if you could go up to them and say, well,
how dare you enslave these people and
they're not going to get defensive,
they're going to look at you like you're
crazy because there's no room for that,
you know, for that gap. That idea
doesn't even exist yet. Right, right.
And so the ideal is matter. And when, uh,
when, when they're broken, um, you know,
again,
I think that there's a motivation on
the part of a lot of people who are,
who were more cynical than they should be,
a given the country that they're
fortunate enough to live in, you know. Um,
and this is something that you get
from going overseas to a lot of places.
It's something certainly that I got
from spending so much time and African,
the Middle East for work is,
boy,
you come back after the first trip to
over to those places and you realize you
want to kiss the ground when you get off
that airplane and you want to go around
and just hug everybody.
You see,
because you were so fortunate to live in
a place where things that we absolutely
take for granted over here are
miracles. And, um, you know,
I think, uh, one of the things I
did really didn't want to do, um,
when I was talking about
me lying that episode, um,
I stayed very focused on the,
uh, the incident itself, sort of.
Um, because I, you don't want to,
you don't want to be making excuses for
something like that and you don't want
to make it seem like you're trying
to gloss over and atrocity. Um,
but,
but you don't want to, uh, give
fuel to that idea that like this is,
this speaks to like a larger problem in
our society because I just don't believe
that
[inaudible] right.
If you start pushing the button too much
in the direction of making apologies
for, well, after all, we are good guys
and there are a few exceptions by Luke.
We are, we stand for freedom and
democracy. He's like, yeah, maybe,
but let's not be so quick about sweeping
under the rug. All the bad stuff.
Let's look at it. The guys, we instead
of push on the button off, hey,
look at all the bad stuff.
That means that all of these ideas are
crap and it's not real and it's only
Parker's. He's like, Whoa,
slow down on a second. Yeah,
you got a couple of points where you
are right by are also missing the boat.
It's like, it's almost like, and
that happens in most discussion,
like in most situations,
you rarely have somebody with 100% wrong,
is that they take a powershell truths
and they take it too far and they lose
perspective of the other
side of the equation.
People don't understand
like American soldiers
were killed and maimed,
uh,
in situations that absolutely could
have been avoided if we disregarded our
rules of engagement. And if we made, like,
we made conscious decisions to put
ourselves at risk when we did not have to
because we were trying to be sensitive
to the environment and to the people that
were.
And
I don't think enough people recognize
the historical anomaly that that is.
I mean, that is just a, you can't,
for thousands of years of human history
that is just completely unthinkable.
You couldn't imagine something like that.
And the extent to which we go,
I mean Jocko has talked about
this before in his show,
the extent to which we go to try to
make sure that the people, you know,
the targets that we're, that we're
dealing with our targets. Um,
I think if more civilians
had, uh, had, uh,
an idea of that people would
feel a lot different about,
about what we do over there.
You know,
it doesn't mean that when
something happens like ob of grave,
they're not going to,
uh, react against that,
but they're going to react against
it from a place of, hey, we're,
we're a good country. That shit is not
going to fly. All right? That's not what,
you're not going to represent us that way.
And that's fine.
That's a healthy way to respond to
something like that. Um, but you know,
again, political situation
or whatever else is going on,
like people have more of a knee jerk
reaction to those things that you're
talking about us. You can get that
sense. It goes back to that, uh,
Dan Carlin approach to things,
right?
That ability to look at sinks one way
and just when you're getting comfortable
with Dako conclusions to say, yes,
maybe that is the conclusion we take,
but it's not that easy.
There's also at 20% from the other
side that's not really wrong.
Then you food including that and
that keeps you thinking on your toes.
You don't become dogmatic,
you don't become thinking
purely black and white terms.
You always have to have that nuance
approach, which, and that's the problem.
That's the other pirate jokes.
He's most people that they
can advance to mean weakness.
Then you can't make up your mind.
You are too wishy washy.
You are is not black.
It's an off.
Why two somewhere in there is like mill.
That's also a weakness is the ability to
look at things both ways and also make
a decision that's where can we
can seen as where it's available.
And I think he's funny because so many
of the things that joker burning up are
so about really the kind of human
being that you want to become.
You know about self perfection really.
Cause that's what it boils down to,
which is Dan,
what makes you a great leader because
there no good athlete or without somebody
was work on themselves a lot and you
know when you better get down to the
suppose nothing sounds like
it's that hard, right? He's
all like, okay, of course.
Yeah, that makes sense. So
that completely, and yet
it's one of the Sikhs were,
while the theory may not be that hard,
the practices and the Atlanta team,
you have to be at it every single day
or it's Swiss. It was leap. There's,
there's a great line in the doubted chain
that I was actually surely their road
or driving down,
there's,
there's the law is line
at say my way is Vat,
easy to understand and very easy to
practice, but nobody understands it.
Nobody trap. And I love
it because in tod, yes,
it's not that bad.
It's fairly straightforward.
And yet there are so many steps along the
way where is easy to go their own path.
That is,
the theory is easy.
The practice cs, you need to put
in the work and there's no subsidy.
Each of those steps matters so much to,
because you know,
Jocko was talking about escalation
in those situations. The, um,
the book about the war in Chechnya,
you talked about, I think the line,
I hadn't read the book until I heard
your podcast on it and it just,
it's one of those things that
when you hear it, it's so obvious.
But if you were to just step back from
the context a little bit kind of seems
ridiculous is which is that the savagery
started when people stop shaving,
when soldiers stopped shaving.
And I think part of the reason for
something like that is, uh, once it is,
it's like the escalation is like a
ratchet. Once you stopped shaving,
well now you're a unit that doesn't
shave anymore. Okay, whatever. Well,
what that means is if you're
a unit that lacks discipline,
well now your lack of discipline is
not going to manifest, is not shaving.
You already don't shave. That's
normal. That's totally normal.
So now your lack of discipline is
going to get to the next thing.
Now I'm not cleaning my weapons properly.
And then pretty soon you're a unit that
doesn't shave and doesn't clean your
weapons properly. And that doesn't even
seem like a lack of discipline anymore.
That just seems like daily life and now
your lack of discipline or whatever it
is, is going to go up to the next
spot. And it can happen with, you know,
it can happen with just brutality and
savagery and things like that as well.
We're now, this kind of thing is
just normal. So if I'm angry, uh,
and it's totally normal for us to be able
to smack these prisoners in the face,
but now I'm really pissed. Well, I'm
not going to smack them in the face.
I smack them in the face anyway,
you know,
so I'm going to show my anger
now by stepping it up and
man, well, okay, if that's,
if that slides and the leadership
doesn't step in, well now that's normal.
You know, we're, you know,
we don't just smack soldiers,
we punched and kicked soldiers that once,
that's the baseline,
it ratchets up to that point. It's going
to escalate from there because you know,
that's kind of where it goes.
And that's why it catching those things
right at the beginning and letting
people know that, you know, all
of these things matter. I mean,
that's probably the life lesson.
A lot of the stuff you even talk about it,
everything matters.
It all matters.
Yeah. And not, it takes some time.
Like I didn't realize this when I was a
20 year old seal or a 25 year old seal.
You know, I kind of started
getting the indications and,
and that's why again,
you know,
I talk about training and
leadership because that's
what this stuff is. You know,
putting somebody into a moral dilemma
with no training is like putting someone
onto the Jujitsu Mat with no training.
They're just going to get destroyed.
Whatever's gonna happen,
it's gonna happen and they have
no control over it. And you know,
you got to think about these things.
You got to think deeply about these
things so that you have some sort of an
anchor that's grounded,
that won't get ripped out at the
first person that says, hey shoot,
that three year old baby you want,
you need to be grounded and have thought
about these things in a deeper way. And,
and you know what you said about
people swaying one way or the other.
You're right and people actually want
to be led and they want to be led even
more. So when there is a
pressure situation going on,
when there's something that you're not
used to or that people aren't used to,
some kind of structure, some,
some kind of stress or pressure,
if you can step up and lead at that
moment, people are looking for,
they're looking for a
leader and that was it.
I remember you were talking about one
of the guys in me lie the six foot three
guy and he's a natural leader,
right?
He's a natural leader that
people kind of fall in.
What he started going sideways and it
started just getting completely savage and
brutal people just Kinda, okay. You
know, he's the guy, you know, like, okay,
that guy's stepping up
and, and that's, and,
and there was no one on the other
end of the spectrum to say, Hey, no,
we're not doing that.
Stop.
And that's the biggest lesson from
that situation actually from both the
situations. Yeah. And you know, you know,
people talk about is how can the leader
be responsible if they're not there?
You know? Yes. The leader's responsible,
whether they're the way they train
the people, the way they educated,
the way they communicated, the culture
that they sat with those people,
they're responsible.
And certainly these leaders were
absolutely responsible in these scenarios.
I guess before we wrap up, one last thing
I want to ask you is these days, um,
you say you work a lot with
businesses. You clearly are, you know,
you're working primarily on the concept
of leadership and out to teach people a
better tools to handle it. How
do you go about it? What's your,
what is it primarily like a
business oriented approach
now with major businesses
that are,
yeah,
we'll go in and do an assessment and
figure out where the friction points are.
Figure out where they're
having problems and,
and then we solve the
problems that they're having
through leadership and that's
every single problem in every single
organization is a leadership problem.
All of them,
whether it's your p and is upside down,
whether it's your processes
are working correctly,
whether you got the wrong
people in the wrong positions,
it doesn't matter what the problems are
going to get solved through leadership
and leadership alone.
And that's why we,
that's why we're doing well because if
you've got a, if you've got a p and l,
it's upside down.
You've got leaders that aren't paying
attention to their expenditures and and
their income, right? If you've
got processes that aren't working,
you've got leaders that are in charge of
those processes that are allowing them
to continue to exist without refinement.
If you've got people that are in positions
that shouldn't be in those positions,
you've got leaders that are allowing
them to be in those positions without
either being coached and mentored and
trained so that they can lead or removed
from those positions and you can go
right down the list with any problem that
any organization has.
Having.
There's a leadership solution to
that problem and that's what we
do. It seems to me like as definitely
the thing I'm going to take away from the
most,
and listen you talk about this stuff is
one of the things that struck me as I
came in with a lot of questions in mind.
I wanted to talk to you about like
that I started out with, right? You,
you've got your guys,
you're going into a horrible situation
and there's these horrible things going
on.
How did you restrain your guys from going
and retaliating in these terrible ways
and your response and the look on
your face and everything to it?
It actually like kind of
threw me off a little bit.
It wasn't what I was expecting
because your, your answer
to that really was, dude,
if I have gotten to the point where we're
there in Iraq and there was a guy with
handcuffs and I have to figure out how
to restrain my guys from doing something
I failed a long time ago. You cause you
took it as almost like Ah, well you know,
you deal with it. That was taken
care of. How do we stop them?
We stopped him in training. We stopped,
I mean bootcamp, we stopped to make buds.
We stuffed them in all the way up to here
and I don't want to make, I don't
want to, I don't want to make that,
I don't want to make light of that
cause that, that is a hard situation.
And when you lose guys in a unit of 35
guys and you got guys that are wounded
and killed, there is absolutely, uh,
there is an absolute fire that you have
to control because we know who's doing
it. We can find them, we can get out
there and get and get after them.
And so we, we do have to keep
ourselves in check. We do, I mean,
we had many conversations of,
hey, remember why we're here.
Remember who we represent.
Remember that if we get out of line,
we won't even be allowed to
do what we do anymore. Oh, so,
so don't take it the wrong way.
That in any unit, any unit,
you lose people, you lose your
friends, you lose your brothers.
That is an emotional,
it's an emotional thing and you're in
an emotional situation already and you
have access,
direct access to unleash your
emotions if you're allowed to.
And Yeah, the, you know,
with the platoon commanders that worked
for me with, I mean those guys, you know,
Lafe who wrote the book with me,
I mean he absolutely had to,
had to sit as guys down and explained to
them, hey, let's remember why we're here.
Let's remember that we could go
to jail if we do the wrong thing.
And nothing that we do here is worth any
of you going to jail for any amount of
time. So I didn't mean to make
light of how hard that is.
And, and how difficult that can
be. And, and it's not just for me,
not just for the seals,
but you know,
the marines just soldiers that were
there who are dealing with, like I said,
they're dealing with younger kids
and, and uh, less with less training.
And you know, those, when
you come in the seal teams,
you came in because he
wanted to go to combat.
Like every single CEO wants to go
to combat. They want to be there.
I don't know if you've ever heard
my retirement speech. It's, it's,
it's on youtube. But when like
I made a list and said, hey,
if you want to go over to the eastern
part of Ramadi and live in, uh, in, uh,
blown out bunker and get into fire fights
every day, put your name on this list.
And I walked out of the room,
I came back 20 minutes later and every
single guy in the task unit had their
name on the list. So we're, we're
dealing with guys at every single guy.
That's what they want to do. Now. Do they
get tired? Do they get combat stress?
They absolutely do. Do they get
scared? Yes they do. It's, it's hard.
But we have a guy that at least start
from the position of I want to do this.
This is my profession.
The army, you know, you,
you definitely end up with guys that are
coming in the army because they wanted
to pay for college or they wanted to
get a job or they wanted to get out of
whatever hometown there in and, and that's
how they ended up in the army. Again,
there is also a great number of soldiers
that are just as eager for combat and
certainly a great number of marines
that are the same attitude. So each,
each one of those people,
you have your own challenges and it,
and it is hard and you do have to,
and what goes back to what this whole
thing has been about as the leader,
you can't be the one that's getting
wrapped up in those emotions.
You can't be the one when
you, yeah, I'll tell you what,
your heart's going to be fucking broken.
When you lose guys,
it's going to be broken and you're going
to want nothing more than to go out and
rubble cds and salt the earth.
So everyone is dead and no one
will ever live there again.
But if you let that get
ahold of you as the leader,
yeah,
your,
your team and your men
are going to be in hell,
that's where they're going to end up.
And so that's why the education,
the training, the understanding,
I mean it's so many people contacted me
after I did the, the, the me lie podcast.
That isn't your thank you that they,
they play that meal.
I podcast for leadership training
inside multiple military organizations.
It's,
it's awesome.
I'm so happy that they do that because
when I came out with that podcast,
I had tons of people that said I didn't,
it didn't know about that.
People that were in leadership
positions didn't understand,
didn't know what the meal I'm
asking her was. And it's, uh,
it's one of the darkest
stains on our history.
But you have to talk about it and
you talked earlier about, hey,
I don't want to make it.
I didn't really want to go into too
much of what led up to it cause I didn't
want to make excuses,
man.
I went into detail of why it happened
because I want everyone to understand all
those little things.
How when you cut those corners,
how when you play the telephone game
with your intelligence and you let people
say things that you don't put
them in check and you don't,
you let them use words that are correct
and you've people that don't have a
culture to ask why we're doing this.
And you set those situations up and
you let bad leaders into situate or in
positions that they shouldn't be Cali
failing out of ocs multiple times.
Like that's it.
That's it.
You let those things happen and you're
going to end up in hell and as a leader,
that's your job to stop it.
Yeah.
That's a good place to wrap
it up, man. Me Lie. You lie.
It didn't necessarily
happen on March 16th,
1968 it happened when Kelly failed.
It was ocs.
It happened when the intelligence
failed to get passed down properly.
It failed every time somebody was allowed
to smack around a Vietnamese and they
didn't get called on it. That's when
it happened. You know, the, the, the,
the actual acute incident was just the
result of a long, long process. So.
Awesome. It's great
man. Thank you so much.
Thanks for having me on.
Thanks for you guys for what you do and
you guys put out kick ass podcasts and I
appreciate listening to them and
maybe we'll get to do this again
in South Dakota as well. I mean, I can
tell you from my own personal experience,
listen to your podcast as well as
a lot of guys I know of all ages,
guys from high school all the way on up
into their 50s or one guy that I know is
a huge fan. Um, you know, I don't want to,
it's just a three of us and it's
getting a little sweaty in here already,
so I won't get on my knees too
much. But, uh, it's not an a,
it's not an exaggeration to say
that you're changing people's lives,
so thank you and keep it up.
I mean,
we've had have a great effect on me
personally, so thank you. Thanks Barbara.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks guys.
And that wraps up the conversation and
thanks for listening and thanks to Daryl
Cooper and Danieli Bilali for organizing
that discussion and I look forward to
having some more of those
types of conversations in
the future about history and
about human nature and about leadership.
And in the meantime, Echo. Yes.
Speaking of leadership,
if people want to lead themselves
down the right path, the path,
yes. Do you have any maybe
recommendations for them?
Sure, of course they do.
So we're all working out,
right? Pretty cool every day.
Yeah. You work out every day.
Although I got sick, he's just
straight up at arrest. Yeah. Flu,
flu. Yeah. You know what that
is? Yeah, man, I hear bad things.
No, it wasn't shot. Did I
didn't get that. You know,
I hear mixed reviews about the
whole flute deal. Either way,
you're obviously better.
You seem better and better,
which is good because now you can get
back to working out and when you get back
to working out, you still want to
maintain your joints sick or not sick,
maintain your joints.
That's what I think.
I think everyone would agree with me on
that one and the way you maintained your
joints is to take joint supplements
like Krill oil, Jocko, super krill oil.
That's the good one. Talk with
supplements. That's right.
Also a good supplement called joint
warfare. I take those every single day,
every single day.
No pressure, no slack, no
slack unless you run out.
But he the thing you don't have
to run out anymore. You subscribe,
you get the subscription situation.
Everyone, 30 days, 60 days,
whatever, however much you
use or whatever, you've got
an estimate and then boom,
you do your subscription and you get one
in the mail every month. Never run out.
Maintain the joints.
Important.
More important than your power
mass gainer 5,000 I think so too.
Also you want some cognitive
enhancements, which you do. You do.
You totally do. Brothers like you
know, cell phone signals and you know,
pollutions, pollutants from cars.
That's a mess up your brain.
Sometimes you need some
cognitive enhancement.
Jock was another supplement called
discipline. It's a pre mission,
cognitive hands, physical
enhancement, cognitive enhancement,
all in one boom and it
tastes good. Boom. Take it.
I would say take that everyday.
You take it before stuff,
so you call it a pre mission
indicates you take it
before you do something where you need,
before I do a mission,
that mission could be going to
work with a company like, Hey,
I'm going to need to be on
my a game mentally because
we're solving problems for
digging into the leadership situations.
We're finding out what's going on and
the game has got a calm also Jujitsu.
Yeah, but the people always say, well you,
I thought you didn't take preop workouts
and I don't, not for a workout. Oh yeah.
For the workouts. I mean I might do
that one out of every 10 workouts.
Maybe even when I was 21 I take
some kind of a pre pre workout.
Yeah.
It's
because when I wake up in the morning,
I'm not hungry. Yeah. Not even third. I'm,
I mean, I drink water, but I'm not like,
I don't feel the need for some jack me
up during the workout and I'm just gonna
go get it. Yeah. And you
don't really drink coffee,
so you don't even have that situation.
You know?
I don't like coffee and people
will ask why I don't like coffee.
Don't like the taste of
it tastes horrible. Yeah.
So what that did is it
eat like it made you,
or it didn't allow you to get into the
coffee system because that's really what
it is that made out of and hit the call
and everyone says it's an acquired taste.
My question is when something
is an acquired taste,
how many times do you have to drink
something that's socks before you're like,
okay, I like the smell
choir that, yeah, man. And,
and there wasn't, to me, there was no,
it wasn't like, Hey, if I can get this,
if I can start liking this, yeah, I'll be,
I'll be stronger. It wasn't gonna Happen.
It was like,
Hey,
if I start liking this and I'll
spend $4 a day at a coffee store, no,
not happening. Well usually,
I mean like beer, right?
When you first drink beer typically
from the you tastes like is,
I'm not good with any acquired taste.
No, not chocolate milk. Chocolate milk.
Right off the bat,
everyone acquired immediately
acquired wait to try the milk.
That's not an acquired taste.
Yeah. And that's probably why you make
things taste good because you don't,
you're not down for the whole
acquired situation. Well, okay,
so like beer,
coffee is the same deal because there's a,
there's a benefit beyond just
the taste. So beer is like, yeah,
you get drunk or whatever, and people
like that, but it's like Dang the beers.
Kind of this barrier. Like I wish
it tasted better, blah blah blah.
That's why they do Jello shots,
you know, just get in there anyway.
So after a while you're like,
you know what,
I'll endure the taste to get a bit
of venture. You like the taste.
You ended up liking the taste because
you can kind of recognize certain,
you know, it, there's all kinds
of things. Same thing with coffee.
You kind of start to like the
taste because the originally,
initially you want to get the boost,
the caffeine boost.
Well the good thing is with, with the
products that we make, there's no,
they're not acquired taste
this taste going direct. Uh,
a delicious can just taste
it from the get go. Yeah.
This discipline pre mission
is no exception. Tastes
good. It's like a lemon lime.
Is that the official flavor?
Lemon lime official. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a good one because
that's like a real like broad,
like most people are
gonna like the limit line.
Like it takes a Weirdo
than not like lemon law.
Not that that's a bad thing
you're probably missed,
but nonetheless it does taste good.
I will agree with that.
And I think it's one of those deals where
you can just take it even if it's not
right before some stuff I just drink it.
Sometimes I'm just straight up wants
something sweet, just trade out.
It's all good for your brain and stuff.
Yeah, man. Is that a lack of discipline?
I want something sweet.
No,
because unless it's like a
bad thing because you think
of what you want to break
it down. What makes something a lack
of discipline? It's like when you slit,
when it's like goes beyond
your intentions, right? If
you intend to do something,
but then it's like,
oh,
my immediate payoff is going to kind of
get in the way or whatever, then that's,
that's why it's okay to be like,
tomorrow I'm going to
have a mint chocolate chip
milkshake. Yeah. It kinda is.
Not Today,
tomorrow,
but if that deviated from your original
whole plan, then it's like a discipline.
Like if you're like, oh, I'm really
craving a shake. I won't have it today,
but I'll have it tomorrow.
Even though the plan is,
doesn't entail you having it tomorrow,
man. It's like a lack of discipline.
Just on a bigger scale, I guess. Or
more belong longevity scale check.
Nonetheless. Discipline. It's good.
It tastes good. It feels good.
It won't take discipline to take
discipline. No, that's what I'm saying.
Cause it's going to taste good.
It's gonna make your,
you're saying you know what
it is when you take it.
I was talking to jade about
this. It's like the, um,
you know how like when you're
searching for a word, you know,
when you're trying to explain something
and like let's say out of know your
brain is off. You're hung over four year,
didn't get enough sleep, I don't know,
whatever. And you're searching
wall, what's that word again?
Or you forget someone's name,
like your friend or something like this.
It's almost like the discipline is going
to connect those dots for you. Yeah.
And this is what it feels like.
You don't feel like,
you know what you ever played
the like powerball or something.
Will you ever seen like on the
news how they get the balls? Yeah.
It's like this big around cage
that they spin and all the,
all the balls fly around in
there and then they just kind of,
one randomly comes into the little
shoot there. It's what it feels like.
It's like a,
that's all the words.
It's your brain and that's all the words
and man that correct words just not
shoot. He's not coming in
there. You know what I mean?
But the discipline shoots the right words
in there like no, like one speed, boom,
boom, boom, boom. See what I'm
saying? That's what it feels like.
Take this one when the lottery to check.
Yup.
Same exact thing nonetheless as good.
Get that@originmain.com that's
where you can get all this stuff.
Yeah.
Origin labs, they're producing
it by the truckload for us.
Also an origin main.com there's
some good keys on there.
Really good. Gies only gives I'm
wearing now forever. Forever.
Straight up and they're made in America.
By the way,
the cottons made in
America sewn in America.
Lu Lune is not a verb woven with looms.
Wrong word lottery just
moved into a verb.
Maybe that's proactive.
It's true. See, Shakespeare made up
a word. Everyone was cool with it.
All of a sudden that came
cool and you can make words.
All you need is people to sign up.
That's know the cotton is straight
up loomed in America and sold them,
assembled in them. They're made
in America. Straight up the geese.
This rash guards on their compression
gear, if you will, pants and tops.
By the way, it's not just cotton, you
know? That's why it's so different. Yeah.
Because it's, it's, it's a hybrid
blend. It's not just cotton. All right.
So yeah, there's that. That's
why the material dries quicker.
That's why it's antimicrobrial
type doesn't smell bad.
That's why we're dries out quick.
That's why it's lighter because it's,
it's made from the Getgo
for Jujitsu. Yeah. So yeah,
and that is a big deal if you,
if you take to do too,
and you even just pay even that much
attention to that kind of stuff,
it makes a difference. Yeah. And
then tried to go back to your old g,
you can be like, print, why did I even
do that to my origins sticking with it.
That's why I'm sticking with it.
Also speaking to Jiu Jitsu,
there's an immersion camp coming up or
August 26th through September 2nd there's
two, two sessions. Right?
Early, late session.
I'm going Jackie, you going?
I am going both sessions.
Poor Jocko was so mad he couldn't
participate last time. Yeah.
It was almost like something was there
just bothering you the whole time? Oh No,
no. A lot. Yeah. Well he didn't show
it that much, but you could tell.
Well yeah, I wouldn't say I let it get
to me, but it definitely bothered me,
which she'll every,
every once in a while unless Jack will
be there in full effect this time.
And uh, yeah, I'll be
there and uh, you know,
we can immerse ourselves in Jujitsu.
That's what it is.
It's not a bootcamp. August 26 through
September 2nd. Yeah, that's a good one.
The origin. Yeah. So go to origin main.com
you can look at literally all of these.
It's immersion. It's you through
immersion camp. You can only do Jujitsu.
How many days,
how many hours a day can you do Jujitsu?
What in real life or in the camp?
In the camp and in real life.
I guess technically in the camp
you can do it for 24 hours.
Really technically,
if you really want to know realistically,
what do you think someone does?
Two or three hours in the morning and two
or three hours in the afternoon or bed,
two hours in the morning, two hours in
the afternoon, two hours in the evening,
six hours a day. Yeah, you'll be sore.
Yeah. If you're going getting after it,
which you're not obligated to do,
but that's the freedom you have and that's
how good it is. And that's the thing,
man. So you know how like let's say you
for example, yeah. And you're like, Hey,
I want to on a rule, two hours in
the morning, two hours afternoon,
two hours at night. I, but here's the
thing, you can't just decide to roll.
You got to roll with somebody.
Otherwise he just rolling by yourself.
So that's a problem in the real world. Not
everyone, you know, but Bruh, this camp,
oh, every, every single time. Pining
people, by the way, all levels. Boom.
So yeah, get some, even if
you've never done Jujitsu,
ever still go and learn.
Some did to get off to too.
It's a good way to learn the ground
running immersion. Yup. Fully.
Yeah.
Or domain.com check.
Look at all this stuff and you know
Dave Burke's coming by the way. Yeah.
I'm looking forward to them
during immersion Jiu Jitsu
time. Dave Burke calls me.
I see his name pop on my phone.
Like you know,
every once in a while you'll run into
that guy who can give you that feeling
like, oh gosh, Dave Brooks
calling me. Yeah, good deal.
It kind of like brightens your day. Little
new. I don't know what else is coming.
I don't know if JP is going to come or
life. Yeah, you gotta check the schedules.
Got It. Blocked. The F team schedules.
Yeah, that'd be good if both of them come.
They've been,
I've been noticing they'd been getting
their train on or trying to train.
Yeah man. That's good.
Also speaking of training,
if you want some good fitness gear,
mix up the workout,
keep more creative with the workout
with the movements and equipment.
Could have on it.com/jocko get
yourself some primal bells.
I highly recommend,
by the way,
someone hit me up because we
had this conversation last time.
You said that my workouts were boring.
Yeah.
And someone kind of sided with
me, just so you know. Cool.
Cause I said the workouts can be
boring if you're boring, right?
Yeah. We sing as we did. People
sided with me. Yeah. You know.
Well they're right and, and
straight up. You're right.
Because I think we kind of concluded
that to where, yeah, you know,
if you're boring or if you intentionally
make it boring, it's boring. That's how,
in fact,
the board ill,
the boredom and the boringness of the
workout can be part of a certain type of
training. You know, it's like a
mental endurance training yet.
So it's a whole big thing. And I was
irresponsible to accuse you ever do,
do you ever do a workout where you just
do one movement the whole the whole
time? No. Wait, there is some mental,
not a fool. There's some sort of like,
there's definitely something to that
mentally. Yeah. You know, like, Oh,
I'm just going to do 500 repetitions
of whatever this is actually.
Yes, I have. It was snatch. So get
a up snack. Here's the thing though.
It was I a bus notch?
No. Oh, barbell. Okay.
It was a cross fit. 500
snatches it. No, it was,
um, that's my joke. I forget how many,
it was a dumb amount. Put it that way.
Well, at the time I thought it was anyway,
I forget how much it was. Probably you
too. I mean it's already done.
I think it was 200 board at FFT.
You powered through those last five
reps though. I'm a sucker then.
I did it, but that was it. That's the
only thing. Super Sore the next day.
Yeah. But that's it. Yeah. Snatch. Let's
not just kind of a fun exercise though.
That's the thing. Yeah. Well, well,
yeah. Even though it's really fun,
but the movement is like, it's more
dynamic than just a, um, you know,
like the thing with exercises like
the snatch, if you're not focused,
all this one's real simple.
But if you don't focus box jump.
If you let your mind wander
during a boss' Mexican, you know,
you've got an eight inch savage scarf.
Yeah.
Yeah, very true. You ever near miss
a box jump and it like wakes you up.
You're like, Oh man, I wasn't paying
attention. Was paid the man on that one.
I don't do that much box jumps probably.
I used to,
I used to box jump like a
savage check all your own.
Perfect.
Super stoked that I know that now.
Nonetheless,
there's some cool workout equipment.
Gear on.
They're boring workout or
not get creative. Boom,
look on there. A lot of stuff. I was just
on their night yesterday. Day before.
Good. Good, good website. Good Info too
by the way on it.com/jocko. Good spot.
Good way to support.
Also when you get these books,
I think I'm redesigning designing
the website. Good. I think so.
I think it's old looking one now.
Now those, it was the anticipated
while you trying to get around to it
rather website was old looking since day
one. But nonetheless. Um, anyway,
back to the point.
Uh,
when you get any of the
books that we review,
including Jockos actual
books way the word kit,
extreme ownership, the field
manual, all these books. Look,
I'm going to list it on the,
and the books are listed by
episode in the book section.
You just click through there
when you get them. Boom.
Good way to support takes to Amazon as
a prime. One day shipping. Boom. Good,
good way to support to buy Yakim
through there. Good way to support.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already. Seems obvious. I know,
but some people they haven't subscribed
and they're not obligated to,
but if you do want to support your
subscribes, good way. Also on Youtube,
I want to say subscribe and
talking, iTunes, stitcher,
Google, play, all that stuff.
And Youtube. So don't exclude youtube.
The video version of this podcast,
which you've been pretty motivated on
lately. We'll say active. Sure. I don't,
I don't count on motivation saying
I try to stick with the discipline.
I see what she did there.
Nonetheless, I am disciplined with it,
but I am motivated to cause, you know,
I understand the value of excerpts.
Now someone emailed me the other
day, Hey, this excerpt of uh,
not joining the military or something
about regrading that during the military.
This is what he did. He had, I think he
had like a medical thing where it's like,
oh,
he couldn't pass or whatever,
but he still could do work
for the military in other
like, you know what I mean?
So it's like became like electronics
technician for the military even though he
wasn't in the military. Yeah,
yeah. See what I'm saying?
So like those little excerpts
can kind of offer this info,
whether it be advice or just spark
other questions and people maybe they
wouldn't have got it.
Maybe they miss that episode or
maybe they just weren't interested
episode.
Somebody pointed out and somebody made
a really funny meme that it showed,
he didn't show you make an extra,
but it showed like someone discovering
excerpt and like, wow, this is awesome.
And then it said, oh no, episode
number attached to the SEC, sir.
So meaning, Hey, glad I got the
extra. Now where can I find this?
So in the future we may want
to add the episode number.
Yeah. So did you know that there was a
big meme more? No, it was on the boards.
I need more,
I guess I can't really follow it 100%
because it was all on reddit and,
but I read an article about,
there was like a legit me more,
what's a name anymore though?
Tell me more is different memes
going back and forth at each other.
But there was a me more and I've, I've
seen a funny, somebody asked me one time,
they had a, they had a ball cap. You ever
seen the ball caps that say, you know,
Vietnam War veteran or Afghanistan,
Afghanistan or Operation Iraqi Freedom
of war veteran or something like that.
Someone wrote me up or sent me
a picture and said it is this,
is it offensive for me to wear this
hat? And the hat said, you know,
survivor of me more.
And it looked like it looked like a
legit veterans at and I kind of was like,
no man, as far as I'm
concerned, you're good.
I don't know what you've
been through on the I,
I don't know what the meaning more is.
I will,
I'm going to look into it more on
reddit. Yeah. Tough. Rarely had
to do with sequels.
I can't
say the whole,
I don't understand it well enough,
but I understand it well enough
to laugh and think. It's funny.
I think it's very compelling.
Hundred percent me more
those means are funny, man.
Funny. That's good. That's a good thing.
Nonetheless, excerpts. I do put
the episode on there. By the way.
Here's the thing. When you go
and when you go to a Youtube, oh,
you gotta go to the read more or
something. You got to click on read more.
That's the thing. So it
looks like, by the way,
I was reading youtube comments the other
day. Oh, dance. It's bold. It's a wacky,
wild adventure. Someone wrote, why
are we even making these comments?
Jocko and echo. Don't even read them.
Guess what? Jocko reads on my write them.
Dang, there you go. Me More. What's
going on? I had to do something.
Take some, some kind of act. It's
just read the comments. Actually,
that makes sense. But here's the
thing about youtube comments. This is,
this isn't new by the way.
So a lot of people know this straight
where youtube comments seem to be.
Maybe this is probably other forums
and stuff where they get worse,
but youtube has the most potential for
terrible comments and for no reason to,
so there's isn't be,
because it's completely unregulated.
Well you know they're words on a
Facebook comment or on a Twitter comment.
Generally it's your purse. You're,
you're a human being. Yeah. On,
on Youtube you're just,
you're just a, yeah,
you can create an account pretty easy
and they can't really think. Yeah.
So it's anonymous, you know, it's, you
know, close to an anonymous. So the,
the key is,
or the kind of the thing,
the result is like if you're going
to read youtube comments on your,
your content to a, you got a got to have
fixin in real thick skin cause they get,
it's like they're trying to hurt your
feelings. Like they're trying, you know,
I think they are and they can be.
And that's the thing.
People are creative and creativity
is just, is a really broad thing.
And people don't, when they use
creativity to try to like try to get you,
they can if you don't have fixed in.
And I've experienced this case,
you don't remember when he used
to do the hand auto show. Right?
So that's a anytime you're doing
like comedy stuff or I dunno,
like any kind of like
creative stuff to me,
your stuff now he's really hard to be
like good socks and try to like, you know,
so it's kind of easy. Well I think
we kind of have it easy in that way,
in that way because if someone's like
jock was so stupid or something like that,
they make themselves look dumb
cause it's so obviously not stupid.
But when you do like a comedy thing,
well at, to me anyway, I dunno.
So when you do like a comedy thing
or you know, something like that,
there's something of the
nature of [inaudible] or
bikini girls doing lightsaber
fights or something like that.
People were going to tear that stuff
apart and the stuff they say, it's like,
Dang,
I didn't even think about that.
But now I'm kind of have a complex about
my videos now, you know, kind of thing.
So that's how I started
on youtube by the way.
So I was like kind of new to youtube and
putting stuff on when he got an audit
got shredded and the feelings,
and here's the thing too,
but you don't really have thick skin.
I would say then that that time
it was thinner in the beginning.
I don't think anyone really as sick skin
unless they have the heads up going in.
So, and here's the weird
thing. It's like most people,
they like it because their friends
have had natto or something like that.
But then one, one guy now after like
50 comments of like a hobby scoops,
lyrics hold, there's videos is funny
or whatever. One guy says it sucks.
You're like, fuck, it sucks. I know
it's, you know, he gets to you.
It's weird how that works.
Nonetheless,
the point is you reading the
youtube comments is a Wacky, wild,
bold adventure and I respect you
for going, going on that adventure.
Nonetheless, Joppa reads them. So
boom, question answered, right?
Was it a question or do
they say they don't know?
You don't use a statement
saying straight up.
They don't really know why
we're even writing anything.
Jocko and echo don't even read
these comments. Meanwhile,
he wrote that I was borderline like maybe
I should just respond for once and say,
Hey, what I'm right
here. We're eating. Yeah.
And the darkness that came out of the
darkness for once. Yeah. Man, that's good.
Maybe that's another way to engage, right.
I just figured like Youtube comments,
um, is kind of, I don't know. It's not
as authentic, you know, random. Uh,
what is your anonymous yeah. A lot of
stuff, which is kind of a bummer. Yeah.
Nonetheless,
if you want subscribe to
the Youtube Channel for the
video version and excerpts,
which are valuable,
I've come to know the value
of excerpts and um, you know,
some enhance excerpts calling me enhanced.
Put some music on there,
some text, kinetic typography. You know
what that is. Does that sound familiar?
Well, Connecticut, I know what
that means. I know what that means,
so I'm putting it together. Yeah, man. So
you know, Eh, when you put it on a video,
it's like you know the words kind
of ad and get animated on there.
That's what it's called. Yeah. You liked
that stuff. I liked it too. It does.
It becomes kind of captivating. Some
people aren't really good at it, man.
They do it anyway. Nonetheless. Cool
videos on there. If you want to subscribe,
subscribe.
Good way to support also chocolate store.
It's called Jocko store.com.
It's called Jacqueline store.
The website is [inaudible] dot
com that's what I'm saying.
That's where you can get your shirts.
Same Shirt Jocko wears every day.
The victory MMA shirt. You
can get it there. Boom.
Also discipline equals freedom.
Get after it.
Some bumper stickers on their decals, on
their hoodies, on their women's stuff,
on their patches.
Velcro beanies.
I haven't seen any of these guards are
on their cashmere blend directly picked
from the high mountains of Bulgaria.
Uh,
well the good news about the
nice is that they're in route,
in route, en route, en route.
That's any car on the way.
Straight up put in the order.
We came down to the all the stuff
and then they're on the way, man.
Straight up here. Well, you know,
Christmas is on the way, right?
It'd be worth the wait,
I think, in my opinion,
unless it's called Jocko store.com
if you want something, get something,
check out the stuff. If you like it,
get something good way to support.
Also psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
it's an album on iTunes and stitcher
and wherever you can buy mp3s.
It's an album Jocko album with tracks,
Jocko tracks.
I don't think you can buy mp3s
on Stitcher, by the way. Oh yeah.
Don't go to stitcher then for good
Amazon music or something like that,
or Google play or wherever
else you can get them.
You understand what I'm saying? Anyway,
it's a track with Jocko helping you. Okay.
When you go on your path, you have
moments of weakness. We all do.
All of us do. Even Jocko, I think,
but when we, when I have
moments of weakness, you know,
if Jack was there to be like, hey, look,
not yell, I want Jocko yelling at me.
I don't want anyone yelling. Really.
Some people do. I get it. I respect.
But personally in a lot of us don't
want Jocko yelling at us. No need,
no need. Right. A
yellows is not impactful.
It's a short impact. Yeah. Yeah.
And then the gelling is kind of
like pragmatic telling me like, oh,
here's an actual reason why
should not mess this workout. Yup.
And that's exactly what I should not
eat this doughnut. Exactly right.
That's exactly what it is.
One of my favorite Twitter things of all
time is that little girl from Australia
saying imitating me saying sugar coat.
It was good.
100% good.
That's a good one. Yeah.
Notice you weren't yelling on
though. She kind of made it.
It's funny the way she heard it
was almost like yelling, you know,
shoot are coded.
Yeah. Yeah. Very good.
Unless it's practical Jocko telling you
practically and pragmatically why you
shouldn't skip to work at
why you shouldn't or why
procrastination kills you.
So it's like you'll be like,
oh shit.
It's almost like you gain
a deeper understanding of
the potential weakness and
you can get past it works a hundred
percent success rate in my experience,
Jack. Well also you've got, if you want,
you can get some Jocko white tea and
you know what? Sure, it tastes good.
Sure it's got antioxidants in it,
but let's face it,
there's no other drink that's
guaranteeing an 8,000 pound deadlift.
No other drink. Not that I know. No.
So do you get some Jocko white tea,
get an 8,000 pound deadlift check.
Next question. A lot of people do.
You do all kinds of work it out.
They try and try the
triple complex to the OB.
They could come up with these big plants.
Just drink Jocko white tea.
You're there, no knees, no
need even play around. Check a
books way. The Warrior Kid, we talk about
staying on the path. What's the path?
A lot of people are looking for the path,
but what if someone could
show you the path? Well,
the phone,
the fact is the path can be found and
it's simply and clearly put forward to you
in the way of the warrior kid books of
which there are two and they will put
kids on the right path is
the book everyone wishes
they had when they were kids.
Everyone.
Everyone that's it has said to me,
I wish I had this when I was getting like,
yeah, me too. Me Too. I didn't have it.
How did just kind of wander around
trying to figure out where the path is,
but no,
you don't need to have that happen.
So a lot of the path is covered in book
one, but now book two is coming out.
Weigh the war. Your kid too. It's called
Mark's mission. More lessons learned,
controlling your temper,
saving money.
How to get people to
stop making fun of you.
That's important to know as a little kid,
right?
Controlling fear of failure because a
lot of kids, you don't think of this.
When you think of fear of failure,
you think of like an adult that say,
don't you know, I don't really
for new foot one step out, man,
that guy is afraid of failure like that.
That's for kids even more so kids don't
even want to try something because we're
going afraid they're going to look bad.
I remember my daughter when
she was 13 my oldest daughter,
she was 13 years old and she was kind of
interested in something. I was like, oh,
why don't you try it? And she's
like, I'm too old to start.
She's 13 you know what I mean?
So how do you get kids to
come over that? Well, you,
you introduce them to these books,
building a business,
that's something that kids don't think
about very often. They should be,
they should be thinking
about starting businesses,
earning money when they're young. Learning
the value of money when they're young.
They should absolutely be learned about
this book's gonna make every kid better.
It'll make them a warrior kid. So here's
what you do. You preorder the book.
Now that's my recommendation marks
mission preorder the book. Now.
There's a couple reasons
why. Number one, you don't,
it's happened with other
books that I've come out with.
If you don't order it preorder,
then guess what?
You go to order and it's not out of stock
and then you're mad at me. Everyone's,
Ooh, you're supplied. Bandwidth is working
really well there, Jocko. Hey, okay,
I'll take ownership of that. Guess
what? Order the book and you'd have it.
How's that? That's my
recommendation, so if you ordered,
the other thing that's good
about it is if you order,
it spreads the word and more kids will
hear about it because there's no big
advertising. I just got a thing the
other day from somebody who was a tool,
a social media, I think
it was Twitter. You know,
you might want to check with your,
I don't know what your marketing
teams telling you, like, Hey,
I don't have a marketing team over
here to me and echo, we're kicking it.
So if you want to help spread
the word order the book,
it's due out April 24th it's
way the warrior kid to Mark's.
And if you want to see a,
an actual warrior kid in
action, checkout Irish oaks,
ranch.com Aiden,
he's a warrior kid.
He's only 12 years old but has his
own business speaking to businesses.
You can get his soap that he makes from
goat milk. Very good soap by the way.
Yeah,
it's got a good motto to the motto of
the soap is stay clean. Sounds simple,
but you know what? There's
a lot of layers there. A,
don't forget the discipline equals
freedom field manual eating, thinking,
fighting, working out life.
We're talking about life.
Get the manual on how to live your life.
The field manual discipline
equals freedom for the amp,
for the audio version of that. You can't
find it on audible cause it's not there.
The audio version of discipline equals
freedom field manual is on iTunes,
Amazon music, Google play, other MP,
three platforms as an album with tracks.
Don't you know.
Also extreme ownership,
combat leadership for business
and life and on top of that,
Leif Babin and I are bringing out
the follow on to extreme ownership.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership.
It's got knowledge and lessons learned
from the battlefield and business and
life.
You can preorder that book right now.
Did you know that can preorder it now
if you didn't know that you can preorder
that book now comes out
September 25th again,
if you want to get the book
when it comes out, order it now.
Yeah.
Otherwise it'll sell out and
you'll be mad at me. Hey, I'm down.
You can be mad at me. That's
cool. For even more leadership,
we have national on front.
That's my leadership and my
leadership consulting company. Me,
Leif, Babin, JP Denelle, Dave Burke.
You want us to come out
to work with your team?
Email info@echelonfront.com or you can
check out that website and of course
there's the muster,
which is our leadership seminar.
We're only doing two year to this year.
Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th both are going
to sell out. They're going to sell out.
So get registered now@extremeownership.com
the entire echelon front team is
going to be there in, no, we're
not going to be in the green room.
We're not going to be sitting back
there drinking warm cups of milk. No,
we'll be with you the whole time
interacting, answering questions.
We'll be eating, we'll be
talking, we'll be working out,
but just basically getting
after it as they say. Sure.
Yeah,
so come and get it out the monster.
And lastly, new announcement.
Roll Call Roll Call Zero Zero
One September 21st in Dallas,
Texas. This is for current military law
enforcement, firefighters, paramedics,
other first responders,
one day leadership seminar about
leadership in a dynamic environment.
So you can also sign up for
that@extremeownership.com
we thank you all for your
service and want to give
you a little bit back.
We look forward to seeing you there and
until we see you at the monster or we
see you at the roll call,
if you have anything else for us,
you can find us on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on the bull hockey echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at jockowillink and
thanks to everyone for listening,
especially members of the armed forces
that put it on the line every day to hold
the line and to the police
and law enforcement,
firefighters, EMT, ies,
and other first responders.
Thanks for being there when we call on you
and to everyone else out there listening,
don't just listen.
Lead,
take charge.
Take a stand,
raise your hand and
raise your voice and say,
I got this.
Then take up your position on
whatever battle field you are wrong
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.